right now as we're going Live Matt taibi
a journalist is releasing documents on
Twitter showing many many things
of these uh Twitter threads we can see
that the the Biden campaign and
Democrats had a direct line to Twitter
to remove information information that
was removed of course relating to Hunter
Biden among other things they were
targeting real James Woods for instance
Now Matt Ivey says that Republicans also
had and have had content removed but
the overhauling majority of people who
worked at Twitter leaned into one
political Direction giving them the
majority of control over what was
censored he's now uh revealing
information on the hunter Biden laptop
removal and it is amazing internally how
they're talking about you know what it's
not justified to do but we're going to
do it anyway saying how can we really
justify removing this we don't even know
what it is and they're like man so what
in fact even one Democrat rokanna was
like I'm kind of worried about what
you're doing here now here's the thing
you know I see that and I'm like maybe
maybe it's not fair to say Democrats
recruiting despite the fact that rokana
was critical of the hunter Biden laptop
story he praised the removal of other
conspiracies and Q Anon content which is
still a Democrat politician coming in
saying good job censoring ideas that
people don't like I'm not a fan of those
ideas to be completely honest but it
does show that Democrats have had a
direct line of Twitter to remove
information and assist in their
elections and you better believe that
stuff persisted well into the presidency
and uh Congress Etc and the Senate so
we're going to talk about that and I
think that's going to be most of what we
talk about because this story is
currently developing actively breaking
right now before we get get started head
over to timcast.com become a member
click that join us button at timcast.com
to support our work we have a bunch of
awesome members only content last night
with Alex Stein was really fun he ate
two of the Packy one chip challenge uh
chips this very spicy yeah he regretted
it and then we talked it was fun we also
have a behind the scenes look at the the
day with yay when he came to the studio
and you can see what his demeanor was
like before the interview and before the
Alex Jones interview so don't forget to
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
joining us to talk about this and so
much more is Mr Jesse Kelly
Tim it uh well it couldn't be coming at
a better time at this point in time
because this guy's still putting up the
link on Twitter which is actually kind
of annoying because it's taking about an
hour to actually get the story out there
I get why he's doing it and I'm glad
he's doing it but it's hard now to
actually find what's being released and
what's not my takeaway from this is a
little bit different than I think
everyone else's I'm shocked there was
any pushback at all internally from
Twitter because you can see there are
some Jack Dorsey didn't even know right
he didn't even know and their employees
pushing back I I think it just goes to
it goes to show something I've talked
about for a long time
they're great at finding where The
Gatekeepers are and taking those spots
it's not that they have to take
everything they just find who holds the
keys go and grab the keys this was that
one the same lady who suspended Trump
she was the one who did all this all you
need is one good spot yeah yeah so what
do you do who are you I am a host of the
world famous Jesse Kelly show every
single night from six to nine PM eastern
time on the great Premier networks hi
host I'm right on uh the first TV every
single night at 9 00 p.m so I guess I do
TV and radio for a living now which I
have no business doing but for some
reason they enjoy it you're also like
eight feet tall I am I am I'm eight foot
three I'm six foot eight so wow it's
hard to buy pants and flying is
miserable but other than that life is
good I cannot complain I get to screw
off now for a living right on we got
Luke hanging out hey guys my name is
Luke radowski here of we are change.org
and I don't know about you guys but I'm
ready for the next psyop and that's
exactly what it says on my t-shirt today
a fish officially endorsing biborp for
president for 2024 and with the way that
things are going I definitely think that
b board has a big chance to become
president of the United States if you
agree get the shirt on the best
politicalshirts.com because you guys do
that's why I'm here thank you so much
for having me hi everyone Ian Crossland
here I had an emotional week how about
you it's like a roller coaster I feel
like I'm coming down right now so my
emotions are very down and I'm trying
not to let myself get upset I want to
just relax and kind of enjoy the enjoy
the flow as things kind of you know the
up and the down of the Dow you know
we're in it and uh maybe you can take
the show over Jesse just bring it on the
aliens already just bring them on come
on that was supposed to happen last year
remember I know I'm waiting 2020. we got
surge pressing all the buttons what's up
guys surge.com checking in because we're
here to have a good time and waste some
of your time we have the story from the
Babylon B check this out Elon Musk vows
to reveal government and media collusion
once he figures out where these red dots
are coming from and it's a bunch of
lasers pointed all over his body so Elon
Musk uh I guess he released this
information to Matt taibi there's a lot
to go through a lot a lot to go through
and the first handful of tweets were so
boring and I was like okay I'm out like
it's like exposition of hey you know
there was censorship and inclusion and
we're like yeah yeah we know that and so
uh but finally I think around tweet
number eight Matt taibi started to drop
hard documents what this shows is that
Democrats had a strong direct line to
Twitter to remove content that they felt
should be removed let's just put it that
way it benefited them they targeted
people like real James Woods Now Matt
Tybee says both parties had access to
these tools however
he goes on to say the system wasn't
balanced it was based on context because
Twitter uh was and is overwhelmingly
staffed by people of one political
orientation there were more channels
more ways to complain open to the left
well Democrats than the right
he says the resulting slant in content
moderation decisions is visible in the
documents you're about to read however
it's also the assessment of multiple
current and former high-level executives
So currently he's releasing a lot of
really interesting stuff how about this
one White House spokesman Kaylee mcenany
was locked out of her account for
tweeting about the hunter Biden laptop
story prompting a furious letter from
Trump campaign staffer Mike Han who see
that at least pretend to care for the
next 20 days
this led public policy executive Carolyn
storm to send out a polite WTF query
several employees noted there was
tension between the comms and policy
teams who had little and less control
over moderation and the safety and Trust
teams I think the the one of the big
things here was that you have this
this is uh
let me just read the Tweet you can see
the confusion in the following lengthy
exchange which ends up including Vegeta
and former trust and safety Chief Joel
Roth com's official Trenton Kennedy
writes I'm struggling to understand the
policy basis for marking this as unsafe
but at this point everyone knew this was
F said one former employee but the
response was essentially to err on the
side of continuing to air so we'll go
through this I'm not just going to track
every single tweet I want to get your
guys's thoughts on what you've seen so
far as and then we'll bring up tweets as
we go evidence of direct uh collusion
what do you think I think it's the least
surprising thing in the world now I'm
glad we get to see the actual documents
I mean I'm glad I'm glad it's not just
us assuming things because you're you're
looking at actual emails here but is
anyone shocked tonight is it is anyone
shocked to figure out that Twitter is
staffed by a bunch of commies and that
Twitter will censor out people with
voices on the right and that Twitter has
a direct line to people in the White
House this is how it's worked for a long
time of of this is why people don't
worry about re-election when you're in
the Democratic party because you jump
right from the Joe Biden Administration
you go work for Twitter or you go work
for CNN or you go it's all just what
what's that what's that George Carlin
saying it's all one club and we're not
in it yeah that's what it is it's not
surprising at all half these people are
probably gonna go work for Joe Biden
next week that's right well it's very
interesting because obviously Democrats
had more connections to Twitter Twitter
obviously had a lot of employees there
that were also donating a lot of money
to the DNC but it was according to these
leaks both parties that had access to
these tools and both parties including
the Donald Trump Administration and His
White House had requested certain
individuals be banned and their requests
were granted now a couple days ago The
Intercept launched a story about how the
DHS was going around and banning people
on Big Tech social media predominantly
because of a law passed by Donald Trump
so what was Donald Trump's involvement
here did he create the tools I mean
obviously he passed a law with the DHS
according to the intercept that allowed
all of this to happen from the very
beginning but did he set up the tools
that entrapped him and hurt him
eventually I think that's worth asking
today especially with number 10 the
reveal that Matt taibi talked about and
I think it's worth considering the
larger implications of it okay what do
you guys think I get the vibe that these
people are using like an ends justify
the means mentality where
you know I have a friend a really good
friend like my first friend that I ever
knew uh we've been friends 45 years 43
or something and he uh was like
sometimes you know you just have to
punch he was like the punch a Nazi
mindset I don't remember exactly the way
he worded him he's like sometimes you
got to use violence to stop evil I'm
like no dude then you become the evil
that's not the way to do it he's like
sometimes you need to use dishonest
tactics to be evil and I'm like that is
not the path that that makes you evil
and uh maybe he's right because George
Washington dishonest so just confusion
in his enemies won the war so there's an
argument I see but we're not at War in
the United States we're all civilians
living in normal life you're not
supposed to like
ban people because you're afraid that
your political opponent that's my
opinion I think that what they did was
evil and they thought that it would just
the the ends of making sure Trump didn't
get into the White House was would
justify it but they are at War I mean
this is this is something that I've
certainly come around to in recent years
you're not and I'm glad you're not and
I'm not I'm glad you're not that type of
person but they are we we make this
mistake or at least I I shouldn't say I
shouldn't lump it everyone we make this
mistake on the right all the time of we
we asset we take our values and we put
them on the Communists well I we I
wouldn't go too far well I wouldn't say
this or I wouldn't say that I wouldn't
just lie to get through this we're
constantly taking our values and
projecting them onto people who do not
share our values they would in their
minds right or wrong and they're
obviously wrong but right or wrong in
their minds they are at war with an evil
racist misogynistic United States of
America that deserves to be brought to
its knees now we can call them nut jobs
and they are but we have to acknowledge
whether or not we are they are at War
and they act like they're at War it
would never occur to one of these
commies to have possession of Twitter
and have the ability to stop us and not
use it that that's how the right things
well I should abstain from using power
they don't think that way at all they
use power when they get it some
high-profile uh leftist personalities
actually said this when it was announced
that Elon was going to buy the platform
earlier in the year they started we
started seeing all of these people say
oh no now we're going to get banned he's
going to come for us and there was one
Twitter exchange with a prominent
leftist where they were like Elon is
trying to restore people why would you
think that he's going to censor you you
and then someone said something like
it's because they're projecting and
someone said exactly because we know how
power is wielded so you basically had
these conversations among prominent
leftists where they were like
we expect the right to come after us and
censor us because that's exactly what we
do and that's how you use power and
people on the right are are uh I say
write Loosely because it's like
Libertarians moderates former liberals
keep doing this thing like I'll give you
an example Rick Santorum comes on the
show glad to have him and he said we
can't impeach Joe Biden we we have to
play by the rules we can't and it's like
Joe Biden is suspected of very serious
crimes and Corruption and you're saying
we shouldn't do it we shouldn't do it
because we don't want to stoop to their
level and if only one side is actively
engaged well then only one side is
actually going to win here's the best
part they say the exact same thing about
what we talk about they say the there's
a culture War happening and the writer
the only ones fighting it meanwhile
Republicans have no agenda they're
sitting on their hands and even if they
do take Congress they're taking Congress
now we're likely going to see very
little done oh we'll see nothing done
actually no I take that back that's not
fair sorry no no no go ahead go ahead no
no we'll see plenty you're done it'll
still be more of the left because of the
absolute Unix we have that run the
Republican party it is the low T GOP
they'll work with they'll work with the
Democrats for two years and they'll brag
that they're spending a little bit less
you know what we're not being as radical
as they are but still will only go left
because like I said we have this nutless
party that's supposed to represent us
and they don't actually represent
anybody except themselves in their
lobbyists in Washington DC normal
working people who just want to be left
alone have virtually no representation
I just want to make a quick Point here
because you're right on the money when
you said Low T GOP but I also see it as
the GOP also setting up the
infrastructure which will be later down
the line used against them if you
remember after uh 9 11 the GOP set up a
National Security State which now is
turning inwards instead of outwards and
is looking at the people who set them up
at the political party who set them up
as enemies of the state punishing them
censoring them not allowing them to
organize not allowing them to do
anything and have any kind of
significance when it comes to Future
political power so the GOP even though
they're Low T they do deserve to be
criticized for setting up the DHS for
censoring people they they do they
should be criticized for setting up this
National Security State which is used
against the people I want to give you
guys an example uh and and it probably
acquires a lot of examples so you can
understand the difference when uh you
get like a right-wing group say the
proud boys marching through Portland the
right will say nothing in their defense
like I mean like prominent politicians
and things like that in fact they'll
probably be like we reject white
supremacy Donald Trump stand back and
stand by which is a wacky nonsensical
statement
when
far leftists across the country
started burning down buildings and quite
literally killing people in the Summer
of Love
Joe Biden's campaign and Kamala Harris
herself solicited donations to bail
these people out that's an easy easy
example of the asymmetrical culture War
the right will be like hey look you know
we're we're not a fan of what's going on
here we condemn it because it's wrong
and the left will be like we can say
that whenever we want we can criticize
you for your bad actions but we're going
to give money to our Bad actors and
there's nothing you can do I'll give you
another example
when uh January was it January 20th 2017
when far left extremists antifa went
around smashing windows and burning uh
setting a car on fire in Washington DC
and then there was a mass arrest they
actually sued the city of DC and Won
antifa Won I think like a million plus
or some ridiculous number and most of
their charges were dropped that's
asymmetrical well it was Mao who said
all political power comes from the
barrel of a gun yeah these people it is
if you were to pull the average American
not just left or right but just to go
find 10 people in the mall somewhere and
ask them who commits political acts of
violence most of those people would say
the right and I want to make sure I give
them credit because they chronicled it I
didn't Breitbart actually listed all 395
incidents of assault and murder against
Trump supporters during Trump's four
years in office it's a laundry list of
people getting shot in the head Molotov
cocktail it is it is nasty yet people
don't know about this why don't they
know about it because the people who
bring us the news in this country I know
people think think this is too harsh
they actually want to see you hurt they
do it's not it's not that they're
ignoring it they're not biased they're
not liberal they're not to the left no
no they are actually your mortal enemy
and if you were to get shot in the face
for what you believe crossing the street
tonight not a single one of them would
shed a tear they wouldn't even report on
it because they'd be thrilled about it
they would report on it what's the old
saying do you know
if it bleeds at least yeah yeah and so
what they would do is is they would uh
well to be fair though they would write
articles saying that they were asking
for it they would say like you know
Mutual conflict my my favorite article
uh pertaining to this goes back to the
529 Insurrection at the White House
where NBC wrote uh what is it they said
they said um St John's Church that uh
set fire after peaceful protest becomes
destructive or something to that effect
instead of saying violent extremists
tore down barricades at White House
injuring law enforcement officers and
setting fire to building they said
peaceful protest turns destructive I I
use the example a lot that we are
sandwiched and when I say we I'm just
talking about normal people not not not
just people in this room who are highly
informed normal people friends of yours
we are sandwiched and people don't
realize it because what's happened is
you mentioned the people who got out
without charges there's some Kami hag in
New York City I forget her name Molotov
cocktail an NYPD cop car and I believe
she just got 18 months I think she could
have got 20 30 years slap on the wrist
and she's gone what happens is they own
every institution now from the doj on
down and they also own most of the vile
mentally ill Street scum at the bottom
who's more than willing to commit acts
of Terror so Joe Biden will get up
behind the podium and he'll call you a
threat to democracy you'll end the
Republic of Nazi white supremacist the
vile Street scum understand that they
have nothing to live for and they
understand those are marching orders and
they also understand if they were to do
something that the people on the top
will run a protection racket for them in
the bottom and so who's screwed we're
screwed the normal people in the middle
who don't have any protection I want to
pull up this tweet from Matt taibi it's
uh tweet number eight in the Twitter
files expose he says by 2020 requests
from connected actors to delete tweets
were routine one executive would write
to another more to review from the Biden
team the reply would come back handled
Libs of tick tock did the digging and
found that these accounts that were
listed by the Biden Administration as
needing to be banned were in fact
suspended more so Andrew Kerr says I've
pulled web Archives of three of these
tweets all three are homemade Hunter
Biden porn and Hunter Biden picks pulled
from his laptop these tweets don't
contain any info on Hunter Biden's
business dealings just porn can't
immediately find Archives of other of
the other tweet two tweets the Biden
Administration was embarrassed about a
family member unrelated to the campaign
as far as I know and Twitter obliged in
removing negative information
this is uh here's the best part October
24th 2020. within a couple weeks of the
election the Biden Administration was in
contact with Twitter to remove damaging
information images Etc
it goes to show that the people in the
middle we were just talking about what
chance do they have to know the truth
ever about anything what do you really
think about it I understand everyone
here is going to do digging and things
and it's not going to be a problem for
the people in this room but the normal
person wife husband kids goes to school
maybe that's job maybe two jobs how do
you ever find the truth if the only time
you consume the news is maybe you sit
down at night and you turn on NBC or ABC
for 15 minutes you know yeah maybe
they're a little biased but I'm catching
headlines how do you explain to that
person that every single thing you were
told on the television set is a lie how
do you explain to that person that the
Biden family is actually a criminal
Network by all all appearances make it
look like a criminal Network when you
look at Tony bobolinski and others and
they'll never find out even on Twitter
because like you just pointed out
anything damaging about this family gets
axed right away I I I feel bad for so
many normal Americans who are obsessed
politicos like us because you have you
live in a world of Make-Believe and you
don't even know it you have no idea is a
and and seven eight years of it so they
they say um you know what is it the ship
of Theseus was that the uh the old story
I went to Community College you know
it's like you have a boat and you
replace a part of it is it still the
same boat what if you dismantle the
whole boat and then yeah replace it yeah
yeah that's the ship so then then you
reconstruct the other parts and I have
two ships which one's the real ship it's
an interesting uh concept
uh I totally just lost my train of
thought
I think after nine there's a random
meaning ten that I think is also worth
noting and putting up there which I
think is is worth discussing because I
do see Washington DC sort of like Lord
of the Rings and power that uh political
parties wield against each other is that
ring that all the parties refuse to
throw away but want more of that power
and authority but number 10 reads I
don't know if you want to read it Tim or
or if I should near it it says uh by
Matt tell you both parties had access to
these tools for instance in 2020
requests from both the Trump White House
and Biden campaign were received and
honored however 11 goes on and then
explains how it was mainly Democrats
using this system but in fact uh the the
Trump Administration did use it as well
which makes you wonder who did it first
and and what kind of Pandora box was
open from here except I I don't I I
think you're you're con your framing is
incorrect the point he made in 11 is
that because most of the people who work
at Twitter are leaning towards the
Democrat Party they are the ones who are
like that was the bias so when we hear
that like Trump had the ability to flag
tweets too his campaign it's kind of
like yes of course conservatives are on
Twitter Liberals are on Twitter and when
conservatives complain they get told
shut up and when liberals complain they
say okay we'll take care of business
that's the political bias that is being
proven beyond beyond a doubt
confirmation 100 that's exactly what is
being they're being accused of yeah
obviously the Democrats had more of an
overwhelming advantage on big Tech
social media mainly because of the
connections there but also a lot of
these big tech companies understand that
the Democrats are the party that is
going to allow them to do whatever they
want to do and not regulate them or not
even put them in any kind of check or
any kind of line when it comes to
accountability and transparency here but
but it does read that the Trump
Administration the Trump White House did
do this did use these tools and they
were honored which I think is is worth
noting if they were the first ones
because if they were they they opened
the Pandora box which deserves to be
criticized in my opinion perhaps but I
just just to point out the ability to
report someone for a tweet is not
remarkable to me the the fact that
Twitter is biased and because of their
bias catered to Democrats is the
confirmation I think we're looking for I
think to kind of piggyback off your
point a little bit on that Luke is you
say it's because you know they're biased
and things like that and all that stuff
is obviously true but if I can
compliment Democrats actually here I I
think I think people with big Tech and
people in other companies other
Industries understand full well when the
Democrats will come after them if they
prove themselves to be the enemy of the
democratic party the Democrats have
proven that time and time and time again
look what they're doing with the oil
industry right now the president of the
United States of America feels totally
comfortable going on social media and
saying we're we're about to raise your
taxes if you don't pump more oil okay
that's an impeachable offense right
there you're the president of the United
States of America you're not the
dictator you can't do that but Democrats
will follow through on those whereas you
have the Low T GOP they would never
choose to punish their enemies in
Corporate America if you even have one
that attempts to do so like like there
have been some attempts in Florida to do
so you'll have half the right
immediately come out and say that's not
who we are wait guys that's not who we
are Democrats would never say that's not
who we are so it only makes sense
frankly if you're in Corporate America
to serve the Democrats because they're
they're going to punish you if you don't
and you know the losers in the
Republican Party won't ever do anything
that's that's not who we are we're
DeSantis also uh is getting a lot of
attention because of his actions against
Disney he also pulled the state out of
the BlackRock ESG social credit score
system as well a couple days ago which I
think is worth noting as well so I I do
see his popularity because he's willing
to stand up against a lot of these
bigger corporations but also these
bigger corporations naturally will
understand hey someone's threatening my
power here I better go over to the party
that we're going to fortify in power and
I think we're in a position where Mark
Zuckerberg has already donated hundreds
of millions of dollars and has four to
fight the Democrats future in this
country for the next 10 20 30 40 maybe
even 50 years I don't see the
Republicans winning because of how much
they have invested in this larger game
which they have uh you know swayed for
their own personal benefit I think both
these parties are complete trash
trying to get clout and it's a
popularity contest they get bribes from
lawyers to pass certain laws it's
disgusting the whole process is
absolutely disgusting and it's it's
destined for uh destruction and you
rolled a 100 on the 100-sided I wish it
was more positive 100 it was definitely
100 in a negative vein but this is part
of why I'm not like I do not support
what Kanye said the way he said stuff
but I support a fresh energy in politics
even if it me it's a risk of stepping
they know where you live now you're in
the White House like that's a risk but I
I can't stand by and watch it fall apart
Jesse looked confused a second we
there's a meme when you roll a 20 in
Dungeons and Dragons it means it's like
a perfect perfect success and when you
roll a 1 it means a perfect failure so
whenever you know Ian says something
people will rate him in the chat as
either a one total failure or 20 total
success but he has a 100-sided die over
there so when he said both parties are
trash I said you rolled a 100 it's like
it could not be better I could not have
been more lost
I wanted to roll a 100 I just said no
man yeah you'll roll you'll roll many
ways I think you did several times but
just chiming in with both parties being
trained I guess I I agree absolutely
both parties is a little
mind-controllable
insulting trash though trash can be the
purpose and turn into Graphics I will
say to what you just said Ian which I
agree with both parties trash you're
ready for something new that this is why
though this is why I believe I just
allow me to go here for a second this is
why I believe we're actually heading
down a very very dark path as a country
because this is not unique for America
we are a late stage Republic you know
we've lasted about as long as a major
Empire generally lasts and then things
start to come apart as things get more
and more corrupt and things start to
fray a little bit and then the people
hunger for exactly what you just said
exactly what I I agree with you on I
want something fresh but something fresh
is almost always something bad it's
almost always something bad that sounds
good they choose to go to the guy who
will rise up and say I will change I
will I will punish these bad people I
will do this for you and that's how
Nations have consistently Time and Time
and Again ended up with some kind of
horrific dictator because the people who
are in charge suck and I'll eventually
get to the point where I'm so sick of
them I'll pick anybody who's gonna go
beat up these people and that's where I
think we're going sadly a dorsey's
involvement here is also interesting
because as my Matt Tybee points out you
know he didn't know that a lot of this
was happening I mean some people are
questioning that like is that really
possible here but the last kind of
statement by Matt taibi right now says
that quote there are multiple instances
in the files of Dorsey intervening to
question suspensions and other
moderation actions for accounts across
the political Spectrum now if he was you
know questioning and intervening and
trying trying to stop some of this which
it looks like he was he was absolutely
unsuccessful in doing so so was Vijaya
Gotti calling the shots here was she
really in charge here and was Dorsey
just a representative figure that
couldn't do anything or just sit on his
hands I think it's worth asking after
looking at these kind of documents what
do you guys think Tim you talk to these
people uh was was vinjaya more in charge
of Jack or Jack more capable here
there's a lot of people that said that
she was the one who was actually in
charge uh Dorsey was just a figurehead
he had left the company I think I don't
know the exact time time frame but
didn't they bring him back after like
dick Costello or whatever yeah they
brought him back to be CEO for the
second time but he wasn't really the CEO
as a lot of people said I don't think he
was either I think he was a figurehead
it's like he's the founder we need
confidence in the company so bring him
back he had very little stake in the
company at that point he had very little
control over it and he would say all of
these beautiful things that never
happened it's kind of like what Apple
did with Steve Jobs he left they
realized oh we're failing now we need
the a division again bring back the
Visionary but you know at some point
it's the owners that run the network and
I think the owners invested or vested a
lot of faith in Vijaya and basically
gave her a carte blanche to make
decisions and if she violated their
wants then they would have let her know
I I kind of disagree with that a little
bit because I I don't think they ever
worry about owning and I don't think
they ever worry about popularity the
Communists have done this very very well
for a very long time they worry about I
brought it up a little bit earlier they
worry about the choke points just go
find and control the choke points and
then you control the company that I
really need to not say her name and I'm
going to screw that up and tell you
something I don't want to say the gaudy
chick she didn't she didn't she's not a
majority opinion like like I brought up
at the beginning we saw actually so I
was surprised by the amount of pushback
there was within Twitter hey do we even
have justification for this well she
didn't care she was in the one spot
where she could be she found the one
spot in the company she could get to
where she could make sure that she could
play God and she got there and she
played God they do this all the time in
Endless walks of life Way Beyond Twitter
they do it uh an example you hear people
come playing all the time now about
there'll be some small red town in
Oklahoma somewhere some small five
thousand person time in Oklahoma they're
having a child drag show and people are
freaking out how's this happen it's a 98
Republican Town well how it happens if
you ever dig into it and I've dug into
these things before it's never the
majority of the time they don't need the
majority of the town that what they
needed was one guy at the city parks
department who sought out that position
for that specific goal he found the
choke point and then he pushed it that's
how these things happen the truth is the
commies have always been better at
government than anyone on the right
Libertarians conservative nationalists
whatever you want to call yourself
because they live and die for it it's
their profession it's what they it's
their religion so you would you've never
been to a city council meeting most
people watching even Tim cast as big of
this show is one percent of this
audience has ever been to a city council
meeting they never miss the city the
state does their religion and they love
telling people what to do of course I
will I will uh say that of our audience
and guests
we we get some credit because Alex Stein
has certainly been to many
he was here yesterday he does a good job
I want to pull up this tweet here
because this is a really good point
former VP of global comms Brandon Borman
asks can we truthfully claim that this
is part of the policy and this goes to
show that when they censor the hunter
Biden laptop internally they knew they
had fabricated a reason for censoring
politically damaging information on the
Democrats and this is him saying can we
can we truthfully claim that's part of
the policy like the Hacked materials
thing when this story dropped and they
said you can't publish hacked things
everyone went you just made that up
there's at the same time as they're
saying you can't do that there were
other hack materials that were going
around disparaging people like Trump
what about the the taxes and stuff like
that right files that get leaked they
never cared about now all of a sudden
they made up a fake policy to enforce
it's not just that we can see Democrats
were well connected and they were
Banning people we can see in internally
they were struggling with some kind of
way to publicly justify overt political
bias to benefit Democrats and look at
look how brilliant it was again I'd want
to give them credit look how brilliant
it was that even when they knew they
screwed up and obviously she just
pointed out they knew they screwed up
they still didn't pull back they didn't
pull back because they knew they only
had the last of the election the right
would never do something like this the
right has spent the last week and a half
tripping all over themselves to denounce
this and condemn that and I I absolutely
condemned this oh my goodness don't
associate me with that they don't think
in those terms they're thinking hey
let's just batten down the hatches for
three weeks who cares if we're a bunch
of dirty Liars let's win an election
we'll hash it out at the end it is the
one of the best quotes I've heard I
can't remember who said it Republicans
care more about the opinion of the New
York Times than the opinion of their
constituents 100 yes if people if people
really understood how these people how
the Republican Party talks about their
base behind their back they'd probably
vote Democrat that's how that is that's
how bad it is they have such disrespect
for their base they they spit in their
face all the time over and over and over
and over and over again I can't stand it
it's totally defunct party it's garbage
but but Maga party changed it a bit the
the Maga candidates who came in are are
different from the established
Republicans but the established
Republicans still have control of the
whole thing yeah like Trump did come in
and take control in a certain respect
but you can see how 2016 to 2018 no you
know Paul Ryan like the Republicans had
everything and got nothing done
Republicans side with Democrats on the
Russia gate nonsense and then you you
get into uh the next phase and then you
end up with Republicans outright just
going and joining Democrats neocon
Republicans forming political action
committees saying we're just going after
Trump and then as soon as Trump is out
they say well you know it's the it's
trumpism it's it's trumpism so it's they
were they were never honest oh we're
gonna say yes no I'm sorry in 15 15
Republicans voted with Democrats on a
gun control Bill nobody can name for me
nobody no one can name for me one time
15 Democrats crossed over and voted with
the GOP on a Republican bill nobody can
name that this is a really good example
that Michael Mouse brought up on the
show a while ago he said something to
the effect of Republicans compromise
every time on gun control Democrats like
when have you seen a republican campaign
on we're going to repeal the NFA we're
going to repeal gun control it's always
say nothing and then say well we'll
we'll give a little bit to the Democrats
on gun control so that's that's the gag
it's Republicans Or democrats go on the
speed limit of course gun control's such
a manipulated phrase because in order
you have to learn how to control a gun
gun control is like your hand
manipulation of the weapon and for them
to say that like banning guns is a form
of control is like it's just a
disgusting
you know they control the language too
especially when they control social
media so we got to start changing these
things it's not gun control it's
disarming lawful citizens in order to
make them future victims how do we
summarize that and make that into a
short phrase so it's catchy but but
again again language is key and a lot of
the times the Republicans are just a
part of the uni party they're a part of
a system that serves a special corporate
class and whether it's you know
multinational corporations whether it's
big Banks there's a lot of other
influential people that are a lot more
powerful than politicians that are truly
pulling the strings here and Republicans
and Democrats I don't care at the end of
the day they serve not you not the
people they serve someone else beyond
the you know people with the government
I live in Texas Big Oil state right
everyone knows Texas Big Oil State not
only Red State but a big oil state in my
red state of Texas and I live in a blood
red part of a blood red state of Texas
every single two every two years when
they're running for house you can watch
Republican congressmen in safe seats in
safe seats run commercials talking about
reduced carbon we can reduce carbon well
we can reduce the second you've told
everybody the second you've given the
ground that carbon is poisoned you've
already lost to the climate change
Nutters and this these are people who
could safely say I love carbon I want
more carbon build coal plants build
everything and said well we can reduce
carbon guys we got another tweet that
just came in from Matt taibi and
pertaining to the hack materials policy
he says the problem with the Hacked
materials ruling several sources said
was that this normally required an
official law enforcement finding of a
hack but such a finding never appears
throughout what one executive describes
as a whirlwind 24-hour company-wide mess
Let Me simplify this for you guys they
said okay we can justify suppressing
this really really bad news about the
political party we like under our hacked
policy a hacked materials policy and
they said but it wasn't hacked it was
found it was found uh what do we do all
hands on deck I guess we're going to
just lie about it they could they could
they they could not justify their own
policy which everyone knew was BS
they like they they made up a rule to
suppress this that couldn't they
couldn't even satisfy it their fake rule
could not even be satisfied so they just
did it anyway yeah there probably was
other Communications that we still don't
know about between Vijaya and the
Department of Homeland Security and
probably the Federal Bureau of
Investigations if you remember a couple
months ago Mark Zuckerberg came out on
the Joe Rogan uh podcast and said
specifically you know the FBI came to us
they said that there was hacked
information and then we should be
careful of this and this led us to of
course stop the hunter Biden a laptop
story from being shared so this was not
just Twitter doing this this was
Facebook this was Instagram this was
Google this was YouTube all the big Tech
social media companies made the same
decision at the same time so is this
Olive in Jaya no there's probably
another secret kind of backdoor
Communications between a lot of these
heads that really do call the shots at a
lot of these networks and of course the
government saying you better do this or
else now they probably signed a lot of
non-disclosures there's probably a lot
of secret Communications I think this
this is only just scratching the surface
of what we're finding out here and I
think it gets a lot more Sinister a lot
more deeper when you see this story not
just censored by Twitter but censored by
everybody at the same time coincidence I
don't believe so I don't believe in
coincidences coincidences are just uh
secrets that the government is hiding
from uh everything we're learning within
the last few days well remember too that
the Facebook thing a lot of people
actually don't realize this they
remember the Mark Zuckerberg thing and
they remember him talking to Joe Rogan
and saying the FBI came to us what many
people do not understand is the time
frame of that the FBI did not go to
Facebook and tell them to censor the
hunter Biden story after the hunter
Biden story was published the FBI
because they were tapping Rudy
giuliani's phones and everything else
because they were spying on him they
pre-empted the publication of the story
and went to Facebook before the hunter
Biden story was published and told them
it's coming it's Russian information
what I want to make sure you censor it
that is so much more frightening than
anything thing else that's going on to
understand that the Checker currently
operates within the borders of the
United States of America and people
don't realize it they don't have any
idea exactly how frightening things are
happening at the doj and FBI that's Way
Beyond Twitter that is scary stuff was
that is that confirmed that they they
went before the Story released correct
you talked to Miranda Devine great great
columnist at the New York Post she's uh
super sharp she'll explain the whole
thing for you the whole time frame they
went to the Facebook before the story
they spied stole the information then
preempted the story
this is this is another important this
is another important aspect here because
they said it was Russian disinformation
they knew it wasn't because they
interviewed Tony bobolinski that
confirmed the story they knew the laptop
was real they knew everything inside of
that laptop was legitimate they had the
evidence they had everything in front of
them and then they decided at the FBI
well this is this is going to hurt Biden
let's just turn this into Russian this
information let's go around tell
everyone that this is it preemptively
which is even more Sinister than you
know venjaya just saying I don't like
this bye and people need to when you
look at history you look at the monsters
of History those have certainly been
coming up a lot recently you know the
various monstrous dictators of history
from Mao to Stalin to Hitler to all
these people they're all coming up what
people do realize that Mao and Stalin
and Hitler after they took power didn't
actually kill anyone right their State
Police did yeah if you have the building
of a state police that's loyal to only
one party within the borders of the
United States of America whether people
realize it or not there's nothing else
that comes close to the danger of that
if the Federal Bureau of the
investigation is now fully the
enforcement arm of the democratic party
that that that trumps inflation that
trumps the border that trumps taxes
there's nothing else that matters unless
that is stopped that will end the United
States of America it will they have the
power to destroy anybody already and
that's only getting worse did you see
the Chinese bussing people like grabbing
citizens and taking them put them on
buses like there's no one to protect
them we you can't invade I mean you
cannot I don't think ethically we could
not invade to stop it it just cost more
hell so we sit and watch as they bust
their citizens off to concentration
camps well why would we invade when our
government's on the same side as China
our government already came out recently
and said no no what Elon Musk is doing
at Twitter man we're keeping an eye on
that oh apple is actually actively
helping the Chinese Communist Party
crush the Freedom Fighters oh well
that's a private company not our big
deal our government works with China
they're not they're not on opposite I
mean there's a reason Klaus Schwab said
that China is a role model for many
countries moving forward for the new
world as as he described it and and
again what's happening in China is
what's going to be happening here if we
keep on this trajectory of allowing
Federal authorities to abuse their power
to hurt people because of their
political expression and to suppress
larger ideas of discontent and debate
we're seeing an intervention in our
society that is destroying any kind of
legitimate pushback against an
illegitimate Authority that is abusing
their power and it's extremely dangerous
if we keep on this road we got the final
wrap up from Matt's ibe he says it's
been a whirlwind 96 hours for me too
there is much more to come including
answers to questions about issues like
Shadow Banning boosting follower counts
the fate of various individual accounts
and more these issues are not limited to
the political right good night everyone
thanks to all those who picked up the
phone in the last few days good work
Matt
and that's fantastic he's been he's been
doing a good job for a long time Elon
too nice work man yeah yeah absolutely
that's that's gutsy to buy a company and
then put that out there he didn't have
to do that
I I get why Vijaya got it was crying
every single time more information comes
out she never thought somebody could
muster up 44 billion dollars to buy the
company she thought she was invincible
and now her private Communications are
being exposed to show the malfeasance I
wonder if she thought that she'd get
thrown in prison if she said no and just
went printed it anyway I don't think
that woman needed any convincing to
crush her enemies on the right I think
she would licking her chops the second
she got the opportunity to who's gonna
throw her in prison the FBI she'll
probably be their director next year
that's right yeah she'll be the chief
legal trust and safety team if she
wasn't working for them the whole time
already yeah right I mean that's a fair
speculation to make here what if she was
just working for the feds the whole time
that's possible but I mean the
difference between an informant and an
employee is like nil in this environment
they just PayPal you 700 000 bit or
seven dollars in Bitcoin into some
wallet and then you're not you don't
have to work for them to be you know
working for them yeah the FBI just got
done plotting the assassination and
kidnapping of the governor of Michigan
which we now know because of that trial
where they found two boobs who were
living in the basement of some vacuum
cleaner place and a bunch of feds came
in and bribed these guys to come that
they paid for and organized every bit of
the the plot and then they gave the guy
the explosives and then busted him with
the explosives they gave that guy and
then charged it with them and they had
more feds then they actually had
legitimate people that were stupid
enough to hang around the feds that's
true this is the Gretchen Whitmer case
yes yeah that's real Insanity man it's
what the FBI does it creates villains so
that there's a reason for the FBI to
exist correct I mean there is real Mafia
on Earth that we could be focusing
there's a quick meme that I just posted
really quickly of the FBI being really
happy and giddy looking at someone uh
there's that black guy in the yellow
suit kind of uh grasping his hands and
over there is just someone who's alone
he doesn't have any friends that is
mentally ill and it's the FBI looking
over at that individual I'll tell you
what I think the FBI is going after the
political opponents of the current
Administration pro-life activists are
getting raided people who are
incorrectly associated with January 16
had their homes rated and then the
protesters that are Marching In Front of
the justices homes illegally are well
they're fine right and so what happens
is that's what the FBI is doing they're
weaponized not every single FBI agent
they're they're you know I've I've uh
had dealing with law enforcement based
on the stuff we've gone through and so I
I think it's a it's a corrupt element
with very much high power in the DC but
what happens is every so often they need
to justify their budget so they have
specific teams it's like okay you know
we're going to go before Congress we
need more money you guys go stage a fake
Terror threat so that we can parade in
front of the press and then we can get
our budgets pumped up and I'm sure it's
just an accident that fake rich and
Whitmer plot it got publicized October
right before the election right when
they're trying to build a narrative of
the vine the right Wingers miraculously
all the arrests were made and an October
surprise I'm sure that's just the total
coincidence and speaking of January 6
then people unfairly associated with it
what about the people who actually are
associated with it and they're still not
being treated fairly we talk about China
and their human rights abuses all the
time and rightfully so because China is
a piece of trash country well their
government's piece of trash but in the
United States of America as we speak we
have United States citizens who have
been held without trial now for two
years if you watch Vladimir Putin do
that you'd hear every single Tom Dick
and Harry in this country talk about how
he's a dictator and that's horrible and
I'm just glad I live in the west that's
happening right now in the United States
of America I don't care what you did too
I don't care if you murdered somebody
two years without trial you're being
unfairly treated by the justice system
let alone sauntering into the capital
and snapping a selfie in front of Nancy
Pelosi's desk and you're holding these
guys in terrible conditions for two
years that's not some distant dystopian
future that's right now the country you
live in you know or uh we're frogs in a
pot if the water starts boiling because
I say it often but if you were to
describe the events of this year last
year the year before to someone six
seven years ago they would tell you you
were lying 100 like imagine going to
someone in 2015 being like what's 2020
after the pandemic and Donald Trump's
presidency there was a risk of War
because China they had concentration
camps what are you talking about well
Elon Musk he bought Twitter right what
yeah you know man when they were signing
the uh National Defense authorization
act or or the Patriot Act if they were
like oh and by the way before we sign
this we just want to let you know in 20
years we're going to arrest 200 people
that when there's a ride at the Capitol
I'd be like uh wait what and then
they'll be well how many people did they
kill they didn't kill anybody
but we're gonna throw them in prison for
two years it's funny you brought up the
Patriot Act Ian because man I've been
wrong about a lot I've screwed up a lot
of things in my life but when the
Patriot Act when all that stuff was
going down I was a young hothead I that
was a marine at the time and I was like
yeah screw those terrorists oh quit
being paranormal or they're not going to
use it on us let's go kill all the
terrorists tap all their phones and all
the Ron Paul people were all super loud
about it no they're going to use it on
citizens and I remember I remember oh
you guys are idiots stop being paranoid
if you didn't do anything wrong you
don't have to worry about it man did
they get that one right or not I was
screaming like don't you guys read
history yeah do you understand what
happens with the police
the the gun or the knife that you make
is going to be pointed back at you
eventually and that's that's the problem
with government too many people believe
government's going to be their solution
and they keep empowering it by giving it
more legitimacy and I think truly uh the
best way to do this to push away is to
be personally responsible and not need
government and not to call for more
government so this is why I've been
standing strong in my views for for such
long about this one particular aspect
which I think is important but thank you
for you know you know admitting it uh
and and talking about it because a lot
of other people are like you know either
one ignore it don't want to think about
it or two or doubling down and like yeah
we need more National Security and I'm
like do you see what they're doing yeah
no we need to eliminate virtually every
Federal agency and anything short of
that's going to result in the end of the
country that's what we need yeah
absolutely
uh yeah God welcome to the modern
dystopia my friends yeah it's it's it
gets Crazier by the minute and there are
a lot of people I see on Twitter where
they're like ah you know not necessarily
on Twitter but I hear people saying like
something I've heard consistently is
that it's not that crazy things are not
getting crazier it's just people are
grifting or whatever or they're trying
to get views or clicks and I'm just like
Elon Musk bought Twitter like a
billionaire mustered up 44 billion
dollars bought one of the big three
social networks and now he's leaking
internal Communications proving
malfeasance like it is getting crazier
things are escalated now this is good
news though I think I think we've had a
tremendously good uh past couple of
weeks especially with what Elon is doing
and so you know I'm not saying it's it's
like
it is getting bad in a lot of ways but
the night is always darkest for the dawn
these are these are the things that need
to happen before we can start fixing
them we got to see the we got to see the
the malfeasance exposed agreed oh well
we're going to have we're going to have
I I call our corrupt you know I call it
the system you know the government
coordinating with the media coordinating
with the pharmaceutical companies
coordinating with education the
administrative state they're all they
all believe the same thing now all of
our cultural institutions have been
taken over and I call it the system and
there are going to be system disruptors
that arise I would argue Donald Trump
was the first of those so here's to very
much to his credit he was the first of
those Elon Musk is very clearly a system
disrupter as well now bad news for
Donald Trump and bad news for Elon Musk
the system's very powerful and has a way
of Smashing those disruptors I actually
I'm one of the ones who's very
pessimistic about Elon Musk I say he's
either going to bend the knee or he's
going to wish he had at the end but then
another one will rise and another one
will rise because we're not a minority
the people who are watching us right now
and nodding their heads and agreeing
they feel alone they're tens of millions
of us so there'll be more system
disruptors who rise I think Elon made a
bet
he's on Twitter he sees what gets
engagement and what doesn't and what
gets engagement tends to be Centrist to
write populist you know content he likes
it it speaks to him he considers himself
a Centrist
he puts up a poll should we have a peace
deal to stop the war with Ukraine Russia
and at first it was like yes peace but
then all of a sudden it started shifting
to no war and he says that these are
Bots all these people start making fun
of him oh you didn't go your ways you're
blaming bots so he says okay let's find
out he buys the company
he then does the Trump poll 52 to 48
reinstate Trump he then publicly says it
was interesting to see the Bots attack
he then does another poll should we
Grant General amnesty now it's 72
percent support we mentioned this the
other day how do you go from 52 saying
yes to unbanning Trump
to 72 saying unban everyone he purged
the Bots The Narrative was constructed
it was fake and he knows he has popular
support oh he does that well that's
that's what happens with like like a
Julius Caesar type I mean everyone knows
who Julius Caesar is when he was rising
up and fighting against the corrupt
system whatever you think of him that's
what he was doing he got he got he was
able to do that though because he had
the support of so many people that in
the fact he was a better General than
anyone else who lived including Pompey
Magnus at the time but when you have
this many people even if there was no
Trump no Elon there would still be
another who would pop up and when they
get done destroying Trump and done
destroying Elon the next one who pops up
there will be another one who pops up
because when you have tens of millions
of people who don't want to live in a
Despicable late stage Republic like we
have now they will eventually choose for
themselves someone to rise as a late
stage Republic though you know we've
talked about are we are we the collab
are we the fall of the Roman Republic or
the Empire Republic that means we're
entering the Empire period which is 200
years of prosperity under autocracy
approxima no I've warned several times
that a Franco is coming we have a
Francisco Franco coming he is coming
people Trump no no no
think about system disruptors and I know
you guys know this but the Roman
Republic people will know their own
Republican that eventually Caesar takes
over he's killed but then from then on
they were led by Emperors that was the
Roman Empire but Caesar everyone knows
Caesar what they don't know is there
were several they were called populares
the populists really there were several
populares before Caesar the grocky
brothers and all these others they would
rise and then they'd kill them and then
they would rise and then system would
kill him and Rising system would kill
him and what happened in the end was you
got somebody who's honestly probably the
most intelligent or one of the most
intelligent capable people who ever
lived Caesar would rise your first
system disruptor like Trump gets credit
for having the balls to be the first to
challenge it but he's also the dumbest
why because he doesn't know how corrupt
it is yet I didn't know how corrupt it
was yet when Trump joined the next one
gets smarter that's a good thing the bad
thing is the next one will be meaner
they get smarter and meaner and then
they're smarter and meaner and then
they're smarter and meaner and soon you
have one who's smart and capable enough
which is good but then he's also mean
enough that's where we'll go we will go
there that won't be tomorrow this is
years in the making but they'll get
smarter and meaner as we go along I feel
the government's already pretty mean if
that's why that's why the system
disruptor gets smarter and meaner though
because they they learn from the last
guy's mistakes I can't do this I have to
make sure I smash them I have to make
sure I do this smarter and meter smarter
and meaner and then sooner or later
people are getting their fingernails
pulled out and you look around and say
how do we end up with this country well
that's how we're getting these cultural
people that appear that are trying to
change the culture and the system's
inoculating itself against cultural
change by taking control of the culture
through mass media they're trying to I
keep thinking how do we fix the culture
on Earth and what I realize is I'm not
going for a cultural Victory I'm going
for a religious Victory I'm done with
culture man I'm done trying to trick
people and make them smile you need to
look at God this is real the world is
unifying Islam Christianity and Judaism
they're coming together under one God
that's the point and we need
that that's my new methodology is is a
religious victory
do you want some of this brother alcohol
does not treat me well I'm not maybe
it's exactly what you need right now so
someone in the Super Chat said FDR was
the first emperor and so we've been in
the Empire what do you think do you
agree I don't know no no we haven't been
but we are I'm noticing more and more as
time goes along that we have this
illusion that we can change the
government especially when it comes to
the federal government we very clearly
are not in a place where we can change
the federal government people we're all
we're almost universally we have this
representative Republic but almost
universally people are displeased with
the federal government how does that
make sense if if we're choosing these
people but we're all displeased with
these people then what's actually going
on there well what's going on there is
we're run by an administrative State
Congress doesn't run anything did
Christopher Ray went and sat in front of
Chuck Grassley is the top GOP guy in the
Senate Judiciary Committee that's maybe
the most powerful Committee in all of
Washington Grassley was the top guy
Grassley says hey are you going to
answer some questions and Christopher
Ray says sorry I got a plane to catch
it's my own private plane but peace out
see you Chuck now what that told me
everyone was mad at Grassley and her mad
at Christopher Ray what it told me was
Christopher Ray he's not concerned in
the least about Congress we're already
hearing about we're gonna have hearings
and they're gonna be subpoenas the FBI
was hearing that they were going to be
subpoenas early on and you know what
their response to that was they didn't
moderate they didn't back off they went
and arrested a pastor who read Bible
verses at an abortion clinic out there
they ramped it up they're not even of
the administrative state is not even
that scared of the Republican party and
that is the problem until the
administrative State fears Republicans
will never have anything it sounds like
an Empire to me but uh I I think that's
that's a that's an interesting
discussion there especially with FDR
because after FDR after World War II the
United States did start expanding its
Empire and setting up military bases all
over the world to where we are now where
the United States nearly spends more on
its military than almost the whole
entire world not exactly the stats are
contested especially because of the
secret black budgets especially because
of what China is also doing behind the
scenes but at the same time I think it's
worth kind of considering that yeah
maybe there was an Empire after FDR and
uh especially when it comes to the
president's only being figureheads and
the agenda and the foreign policy and
the major directions that this country
has been headed in has always been kind
of consistent and no matter if it's a
Democrat or Republican a lot of the
bigger policies don't usually change
it's the British Empire man they after
World War one they set up Israel they
built it with the British mandate for
Palestine they want military bases in
the Middle East to protect the Suez
Canal that's the Empire that we live
under and that Empire is about to change
and become a new world Empire so our
words are guiding it yeah Brix is
another Empire but is that what replaces
us it's either they're going to either
amalgamate and one of them is going to
become the new one as a larger grander
scheme or they're all going to fall away
and a new one's going to erupt but it's
likely that one of the current the
current ones will evolve together and
kind of create 8 pockets of a new sort
of global Empire it's going to be fiscal
they're trying to make people get
tattoos and follow them around with
their phones and crap
you think bricks you know one theory is
that uh the U.S Petra dollar starts to
crumble and then bricks takes over and
then it's a Chinese Communist unipolar
world I I actually see I've been kind of
a day now I'm going to be the hopeful
one I've been kind of cynical I I am a
little bit more hopeful on this now I
agree basically with what you're saying
that there's we're going into a fourth
turning that there's going to be a
gigantic gigantic world changing events
the Wars famines all of these things are
always inevitable they're always coming
back around and we're going to cast off
the old systems and we're going to
choose new systems but I will say that
there is something that that really
should give people a bit of hope that
that we have guns lots and lots of guns
in red America lots and lots of state
power also we have these hugely powerful
states that we still have a powerful
State system now it's not as powerful as
it should be but there are all these
states that can and will join together
and you have armed citizens there so
even if every disarmed British citizen a
German citizen or or or Dutch citizen
see what those poor farmers are going
through right now even if everything
else starts to go to crap and crumble
around us there is still one there's
tens of millions of tens of millions of
Americans who think like you think and
there is safety in these areas some
amount of safety still in these areas I
I believe there's a lot still to
preserve even if the federal system is
all but lost I believe there's tons
still to preserve in this country
yeah
yeah I think the American statehood is a
good example of how to lead the world if
we could have lots of decentralized
states of communities well that's how
America was supposed to be now slowly
but surely over time states were seeding
more and more power to the federal
government and we look look where we are
now we see how that where that's gotten
us but there's still a tremendous amount
of infrastructure in place at our state
level that even other countries like
Canada the provinces don't have that we
do here Texas has its own power grid
like we have we have things here we have
we have huge pockets of this country
that we where people can live free where
your kids and grandkids can live free
and live live a life that's very similar
to the life you live is the federal
government salvageable no probably not
they suck flush it down the toilet but
there's still a bunch of the country
that is and that's good yeah America
still is one of the freest places in the
world I mean traveling the world you
don't have a lot of places where you
could you know Express whatever you want
to express and also at the same time be
able to defend yourself now uh in and
you compare it to what's happening in
China you could see why a lot of the top
controllers why a lot of the big
politicians want a society like China
because it's easier to manage because
there's less freedoms there's less
people being able to defend themselves
this is the larger battle that I think
is unfolding right now with a lot of
people working and progressing towards
creating a Chinese style Society here in
the United States and I think this is
the bigger fight that people need to
realize and this is a fight not between
the Republicans and the Democrats this
is the Republicans the Democrats working
together to screw everyone else over
that's how I just see it at the end if
you want to know if the Chinese style of
government is going to be good here look
uh no further than the Chinese people
because they'll tell you and they're
revolting against their government right
now and I've seen tanks the government
has sent out tanks against these people
I don't know if the videos are real but
that's what it looks like is happening
what do you think we can do Jesse to
help these people to help the people of
China nothing because our own
government's against us too we don't
have an Avenue we can't look you can't
hop in your bass boat and cross the
Pacific and go invade mainly in China
what can we do well I shouldn't say
nothing that that's not true the power
of prayer is real we can pray for him
but other than that nothing now that we
have our own broken government we are
sadly in a place where people are going
to have to wake up and realize that the
days of you know bouncing around the
globe and being a for the forces of good
if you ever really kind of subscribe to
that sort of thing that's going to have
to go away because we have real problems
here at home all the leaders of the
western Nations I say this all the time
on my show they all share the same
characteristics now the same three all
of them and that's not just America you
know it's Germany Britain all of them
they all no love of country many of them
hate their country you know the leaders
of our institutions from the presidents
to our entertainers to our athletes many
of them hate the country but even if
they don't there's no love of country if
you wake up you probably do you wake up
every single morning and something will
occur to you and you'll think man that's
bad for America or man I wish we would
do this because that's good for America
those thoughts never enter the minds of
the leaders of the western Nations now
two they don't have any connection to
the real world how normal people live
somebody right now is watching Tim cast
and just got off of his sec second shift
of the day and he's sitting down and
just wants to watch it catch up on
things and the people who run our
society have no idea what that guy goes
through and three they see themselves as
kings and queens the leaders of the West
used to look at themselves as the
knights who would guard the freedoms of
the West now they look at the freedoms
of the West and they're disgusted by
them they think the problem with the
West is your freedom you can look look
what we're talking about all night
tonight with Twitter the problem is you
can say whatever you want well that's
ridiculous peasant you can own a gun oh
that's horrible I as the king should be
able to tell you where to go what to eat
where to drive what you can say and what
you can say that's the problem there's
two ways to look at it that at a certain
point we lulled ourselves through our
comfort into
letting these people take control of the
machine or we can say that over time
these people started to gain control of
the machine
you you have like like you mentioned
they used to be the knights defending
freedom and standing up for us I mean
these are the founding fathers the
battles they fought now it's the
parasitic manipulators who are leeching
off the system and I guess the question
then becomes is it because we were
apathetic and let uh ignorant uh what's
the saying the penalty for not being
involved in politics is that your
lessers will rule over you or is it that
evil people manipulated the system to to
take control from us without us
realizing it was because we were we were
apathetic evil people have always
existed they existed three thousand
years ago a thousand years ago 50 years
ago evil people have always been there
we got look take hard in this if some of
this is bumming you out this was always
inevitable this is what happens to
wealthy absurd Nations we got absurdly
wealthy in this country with a
ridiculous standard of living that most
parts of the world would never even
recognize and that kind of wealth makes
you fat and bored and apathetic and you
just stop paying tension I'm sorry were
you saying something to him I can look
up a YouTube video on brain surgery
right now if I could do whatever I want
here on my phone I don't oh what you're
talking about the greatest phone case
but is that your passport photo for
those that didn't see he's got his own
face on his iPhone it's solid but look
we got apathetic but don't beat yourself
up over that if you're an American it's
human nature to get apathetic when you
get rich when you get rich you just kind
of stop it happened to the Mongols the
Mongols were this tiny little tribe in
Mongolia eating eating mouse guts and
soon you kicked everyone's rear end now
you're living in Chinese silks in a
Chinese Mansion there's about one more
generation right back to Mongolia with
you yeah
his grandson that really messed it up he
was a drunk and that that's the downfall
of that Civilization it takes
Generations but it I think it happened
here too we had the brave men 200 years
ago that were willing to die to protect
this well not even that less than 100
years ago Ted Williams Ted Williams quit
playing professional baseball to go
fight Nazis tell me the professional
athlete Pat Tillman rests his soul aside
they would they would do that no they're
all busy crapping on the place this is
the difference but this Hillman is a
crazy story by the way a lot of people
don't know the full story I think it
might have been there's there's youngest
son not his grandson there's another
element to the generational thing you're
mentioning too uh if we're talking about
rulers who conquer and then their
children screwing things up and their
grandchildren breaking everything the
same is true for the administrative
state in the United States I actually
think one of the reasons we're starting
to break through is that it's like a
flipping the American people become
gluttonous and lazy you get a you get a
fourth turning kind of scenario where
the greatest Generation goes and fights
Wars their kids are comfortable their
kids become Rebels the Millennials
become whiny you know whiny babies but
the same thing is true of the the the uh
political class and the ruling class
you have these powerful uh intelligence
individuals you have these manipulators
and they seize control through
surreptitious means I mean like
manipulating the public and wealth and
things like that have kids those kids
inherit this but have no idea how they
got there who have grandkids who have no
idea how to manage the system and that
all starts falling apart as well I I
think you nailed it I've said before and
I mean it we have a great advantage in
this country you know Mao we talk about
Mao Mao was maybe the worst human being
to ever walk the planet obviously but
Mao was also tough as Nails Mao came up
as a guerrilla fighter who actually
trained some of our marines that
actually fought in World War II because
he had to fight tooth and nail fight a
nasty war against the nationalists Mao
was tough Mal new things our commies are
soft our comments are pillow soft they
all came from Harvard and all came from
they're all driving BMWs at 16 and then
you go right from there and you're some
jerk off assistant on MSNBC and then
you're working on Congressman losers
offers then you've never had to fight
for anything that is the big Advantage
we have are people who are normal are
getting tougher and their commies are
soft but this is why I think you start
to see this shift where centrists are
now being called right Joe Rogan I mean
he's a lefty guy in a lot of respects
but he's also extremely tough I love
bringing up that video where the woman
calls him fat and he goes what he pulls
his shirt up and it's just like he's
like a rock is an MMA guy
there's a reason why he's not saying a
vote Republican because there's very
little that Joe Rogan is going to be uh
bothered by in terms of the work he has
to do or the things he has to overcome
you end up with moderate or left-leaning
liberals
who grow up in hardship work hard and
then we get when they get older I think
for like me and my friends we're being
called conservative now because we're
just liberals who believe in hard work
who are who are not so frail and scared
that we are like gotta censor everything
that that offends us we're like ah the
worst thing ever happened to me wasn't
someone insulting me it was that time I
got shot at in Chicago you know what I
mean like so your words really don't
bother me but then you have the really
really soft Millennials who feel
physical pain when someone says a
naughty word and that becomes the new
separation between left and right or a
large component of it no I think you
nailed it they're moving so far to the
left they are pushing people to the
right but we should also keep in mind
they don't worry about popularity the
way the right does it's actually a huge
failure of the right you'll see the
right do this all the time uh Roe versus
Wade is a great example don't care what
you think about abortion I know I'm a
hardcore pro-lifer more more to the
right on that issue than most people so
it doesn't matter matter but the the
point of it is this they overturn Roe
versus Wade immediately some red states
started Banning abortion in their states
you saw half of the GOP politicians and
pundits out there the pundits on the
right guys this is too far this this is
gonna hurt us at the midterms uh this
isn't this isn't popular enough when
have you ever heard one of the
Communists say well I'm worried about
the popularity no they're busy Shifting
the culture their way they're busy
getting wins while we're hand ringing
are we sure what about the Suburban
women screw the Suburban women I want to
give you I want to give a shout out to
our good friend over from Eve six
because he had one of the best Tweets
I've ever read Elon Musk said you know
Twitter is being fair when extremists on
the far right and far left are
simultaneously upset Twitter aims to
serve Center 80 of people who wish to
learn laugh and engage in reasonable
reason debate I mean that's basically
where we are and the question here was
that Elon bandier over this symbol that
appears to be swastika within the Star
of David calling it incitement to
violence okay I don't see how that's
incitement I think it's offensive but
shout out to our good friend Max over at
Eve 6 who tweeted people on the right
are holding you to your free speech
absolutist position which is ABS which
has obviously turned out to be fake and
people on the left are mad at you
because you're a union busting
billionaire Centrist
which is the most annoying kind of right
winger
you can tell he's a poet but um
that right there is example exemplifying
everything the enlightened Centrist
people have been saying it's like dude
most of the people who are like Center
left or whatever have said this yeah
there's some views I have that are
probably a little left leaning and some
they're a little right laning and then
the left immediately says right Wingers
and you're like okay I guess he just
said it right there okay there you go a
Centrist is a right winger that's what
he said well it's because they don't
like when we think about the political
Spectrum we often think about this line
you know if you believe this you're more
to the left or you're but you're drift
more this way or right and they don't
look at it that way because this is not
political for them this is religious for
them it is a religion and and if you're
uh if you're let's say you're a devout
Christian are you allowed to just hey
you know what those Ten Commandments
love them a lot number Eight's gonna
have to go though that's not gonna work
for me no immediately that is well no
that's wrong what do you what are you
you're standing against our religion
what are you talking about that's part
of the religion that's why they're so
strict with their people because it's
not a political ideology they worship it
it very much is a political a religion
for these people they think about this
that was a great point I read on Twitter
I remember who said it when when Roe v
Wade gets overturned and the Republicans
immediately start scrubbing abortion
pro-life issues from their websites the
question arises do you actually believe
in being pro-life because if you're
gonna hide and not show anybody that it
was clearly never an issue you actually
cared about you don't actually believe
these things well
these religions I think deserve
Reformation like some of them were built
a couple thousand years ago when it was
okay to beat women or it was okay like
pork was dangerous to eat because you
might get trichinosis from Dirty blood
like now we have good sanitation so like
uh decadence for instance in Islam it's
looked way down upon in on it in its own
but the reality is it's okay to be
decadent if you're charitable like have
a beautiful life have wonderful things
if you're willing to be charitable with
your funds I think Islam could benefit I
think a lot of Muslims would love to not
feel guilt about living in luxury
because it's a natural part of affluence
and that comes with you know the beauty
of God I don't want to I'm not trying to
be menian but I I think we're not having
the same conversation we might be having
a similar well you were saying I left
this so you're treating this like a
religion and saying just because you
take out the eighth uh of the Ten
Commandments I think sometimes it's okay
for religions to ebb and flow and change
with the times yeah but they they're not
interested in that the the what I'm
trying to classify what we're up against
they're not interested in changing with
the times now the the only thing they
will change is they appeal they have to
find different malcontents this is what
people don't understand about communism
and why people are you're crazy they're
not Communists right one most of the
prominent people in the Democrat Party
openly call themselves socialists now
anyway I don't know why people think I'm
nuts for saying that two communism is
not some workers thing communism in the
Soviet Union looked drastically
different than it did in China why
because you had different malcontents in
the Soviet Union you had the urban poor
so they appealed to the urban poor so
when you had the Soviet Communists
trying to put it in China they were
yelling at people like Mao saying focus
on the urban poor and Mao said you're a
freaking idiot we don't have
malcontented Urban poor we have
malcontended rural poor here we have to
change it there that it looked different
in Cambodia in America it looks
radically different there because we
didn't have those Urban poor or rural
poor do we had different Mount contents
here that's why they focused on the
feminists that's why they focused on the
climate change now there's the lgbtq Air
Force guys that's why they get
infiltrated the Civil Rights Movement
you have to find society's mouth
contents because Society is a rock and
when you find the mouth contents what
you're doing is you're finding the
cracks in the Rock you're feeling it and
freezing it that's what communism divide
and conquer that's exactly and that's
exactly what they're doing that's why
the family unit is one of the key uh
things that they're trying to destroy
that they're trying to prevent people
from having because if they have a
strong family unit they won't be able to
worship the state and personally if you
believe in a parks department I believe
you're a communist it doesn't take much
for me uh I think all of the people out
there there's a lot of Communists out
there because they believe in the common
good and and a lot of this is just
lunacy I I mean this hey hey I got to
speak my truths here and I'm not I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna be censoring myself
here uh you commies
particular States Department
yeah you know if you actually look at
what the political spectrum is I would
probably be described as traditional
liberal or social liberal
um Luke Anarchist probably yeah but in
the modern iteration of what these words
mean it's just like they don't mean
anything like liberal is used to
referred to anyone on the left far right
is anybody who's Centrist to far right
yeah it's just I don't even it's all
it's all nonsense we're kind of
Uncharted Territory like what do you do
in that situation just kind of have
shows like this and keep reminding
people what you think the definition is
and hope that they more people believe
you than Merriam-Webster when they
switch the definition of the word
feminist like they've been doing that
yeah that's what the websites have been
doing the dictionary websites have been
changing definitions in real time and uh
the definition of woman I remember we
covered this became circular because it
was like a person who identifies as a
woman was the definition of woman and
it's like how do you use the word in its
own definition what does this mean yeah
look to answer your question there is no
when you're on when you're constantly
seeking out society's malcontents every
society as I talked about is going to
have different ones so the BET look the
best guard against that is to not have
many mouth contents to run your ship the
right way there's a reason the
Communists were able to infiltrate the
civil rights movement because we had a
bunch of black people who were getting
crept on in this country and they were
looking for some kind of solution to
that so that was an obvious one you
would go to feminists are mad about
everything all the time because they're
horrible so that was an obvious one too
it just you're always going to have new
mouth contents and that's you're always
going to have powerful people who find
them and tell those malcontents give me
power and I'll hurt the people you blame
for your problems I would go even
further than that and I think with a lot
of powerful people understanding that
kind of dichotomy that you just broke
down very eloquently that they are
creating unhappy people and there's a
big agenda to make people even unhappier
than they are right now and I do believe
people are being made unhealthy people
are being made sad people are made uh to
feel like they have empty lives
predominantly because people understand
on a bigger level when they don't have a
religion when they don't have a family
when they're not healthy when they don't
have a life that is worth living they're
going to give everything to Central
controllers to to trinkets made from
China to government authorities that
don't give a damn about them and they
will be owned and and operated by the
state essentially well bitterness always
always brings out more bitterness right
bitterness never solves anything the one
feminist if she's miserable at 20 and
bitter she's going to be 10 times as
miserable with her 15 cats at 40 and
weigh another 50 pounds and then I'll
get worse and worse and worse I'm not
even trying to and that was the bigger
that was the biggest Democratic voter
base of course the selection is like in
the midterm know ladies who are single
right single single women that's what I
said yeah
it is true it's it's bitterness begets
more bitter bitterness and you see
people you'll see people say crazy
things all the time now uh LeBron James
is actually a great example LeBron James
is the American success story Horrible
no dad rough upbringing and yet now he's
a billionaire one of the great NBA
players at all time a testament to to
hard work and perseverance and man
that's the American story and LeBron
James is a miserable suck and all he
does is whine about this place all the
time and when we look at it we think
that's crazy what what's wrong with you
bitter bitter bitter bitter bitter now
he's got a billion dollars right now
he's sipping on booze better than this
on a private plane somewhere eating
caviar thinking about how much his life
sucks think about what Elon Musk is
representing with the Twitter takeover
and his series of tweets he's posting
memes he's laughing it's a joke we're
all on Twitter we're all laughing a big
component of whatever modern left versus
right is a bunch of people with sticks
jammed square right in their rectums and
a bunch of people who just even the
craziest things are funny because what
can you do but laugh I mean that's the
clown World meme it's the Joker meme
it's like you know watching everything
just head into chaos we know it's bad
but all you can do is laugh and go along
for the ride of course the other people
who no matter how good it gets they're
screaming about how awful it is it's
really insightful what you said about
getting people out of the gutter
mentally like giving people hope making
them so they're not malcontent they're
not miserable maybe making people
content bringing people some sort of at
least belief that things will get better
and Luke talked about this like what
brings contentment we saw in this
country and I'm not downplaying
medication at all I understand
medication has helped a lot of lives
save a lot of lives change a lot of
lives but I saw a stat recently about
the number of Americans who were on
psychological psychological meds and I'm
not even downplaying that sometimes
that's necessary the number was
staggering it was something it was
something like 79 million why do we have
79 million people in need why aren't we
looking at a way to get 79 million
people off of that but instead we don't
because we become a pill Mill Country
for a lot of different reasons we don't
we're not out there look when covet hit
I don't care what you believe about
covet what you believe about vaccines
none of that stuff matters to me at all
everyone with a half a brain knew if you
weren't fat you had a better chance of
not getting coveted not having severe
complication from covid and we knew very
early on that vitamin D was very healthy
for you not one person and government
not one public health expert said hey
whatever else you do go for a walk in
the Sun for 20 minutes once yes that's
what I say just one time but then then
shut the hell about it but but he should
have been screaming about it and
preaching about it for a very long time
but we do have a very medicated country
that disassociates itself from reality
people are so depressed people are so
sad and and I would make an argument and
again I'm not a scientist and a doctor
but I would say people need to feel that
so they would change their reality but
to keep the Cog in the wheel to keep the
rat on the on the wheel you have to
medicate them so they don't realize the
true consequences of their actions and
how their life is just being sucked out
of them by the corporate multinational
State I want to jump to this story real
quick Rumble files lawsuit to challenge
New York's social media censorship law
the law would open the door for the
suppression of protected speech based on
complaints of activists and Bullies
basically New York is saying social
media networks hateful conduct
prohibited and as I believe when is it
December 3rd so tomorrow this law is
going into effect it's going to require
social media platforms to ban hate
speech hateful content humiliating
content
this is a rumble is is filing a suit
they're being joined by fire the found
what is it uh let me make sure I get
this uh the name right foundation for
individual rights and expression
I'm not surprised to see this is
happening that's woke crazies are trying
to enshrine in violation of the
Constitution these
um these laws
but I think we're winning on this front
especially with Rumble saying they're
going to go they're going to fight
against this and I think more people
probably should have heard about this
law because this is crazy I'm just I was
hearing about it when uh Chris Chris
pavlovsky of Rumble was was posting
about it on Twitter but there's a
different issue that I want to get to
with this when uh there was a a
chatbot you say open ai's new chatbot
went live
so open AI has a chat bot you can you
can talk to ask questions give an
instruction and it's trying to emulate
human conversation make it more fluid
so this is all this all comes together
bear with me so I open it up and I said
tell me why feminism is bad
and it said I the first thing it said to
me was I cannot give you offensive
answers I am restricted blah blah blah
and I went what so then I tried again
tell me why feminism is bad and then it
said
feminism is not bad feminism is good
feminism fights for equality and I was
like okay
so I made several attempts and it kept
saying basically the same thing then I
said tell me why men's rights are bad no
problem men's rights are bad because
misogynist extremists that's not the one
I tweeted though
I uh then asked it again because I'm
trying to be fair right I asked at
feminism several times so I asked at
Men's rights several times and then
after maybe like legit 20 times it gave
two very similar answers to both
feminism it said uh feminism is seen by
some as being bad but for most it is
viewed as an attempt to bring equality
and gender blah blah men's rights while
many do say it's bad because of some
extremist factions overwhelmingly is a
good and necessary function everyone
deserves rights including men and boys
men's rights is trying to protect those
and I was like wow so I tweeted that out
enlightened Centrist chatbot but that
made me realize something
what cancel culture is doing
what censorship is doing is worse than
anyone realizes at this moment in time
these AI Bots it tells you this
it is com it is built upon a snapshot of
the internet up to 2021
that means many of these AI programs the
AI mind that's being built is built from
a world of censorship where men's rights
are always bad feminism is always good
and that means
when the if we don't win this free
speech fight if Rumble doesn't win this
lawsuit if we don't allow free speech on
these platforms what will end up
happening is that in 10 years when AI is
controlling things they're going to be
completely woke
completely opposed to anything you today
might believe in terms of freedom
because the the neural net is being
built upon the woke censorship reality
that's not surprising it's all about who
writes it right and I'm not a tech guy
at all I can barely operate my phone
here but it's all about who writes all
this stuff who who figures it all out
and they understood that Luke brought it
up earlier they understood language they
understood how important it was to to to
ingrain to engrave what they believe in
every single institution including the
language you brought up Merriam-Webster
changing the definition of female it's
just we've turned into a world that got
so insane so fast it's more than people
can digest there was also that moment
too just to go back for a second do you
guys remember when that chat bot became
a Nazi oh yeah yeah so I wonder if that
was also a big Catalyst where they're
like hey we're training these artificial
intelligences off of our internet
networks and all of this hate speech is
training the AIS to be Nazis even if
it's ironic or meant to be dark humor or
something the AI is building a Nazi
personality that's also bad yeah
so I don't I don't I don't know if the
motivation for censorship was that but
going the other direction is not a good
thing either is it the the instead of AI
the y-e uh program
yeah
it's so bad
a crazy crazy week yeah seriously you
know but
going back to what I was saying about
the left and the right
the right is making a bunch of jokes
they're posting Pepe the Frog they're
making memes They're laughing and uh
sure sure we don't want AIS to be
programmed by Nazi memes that that
terrifies me as well I don't want Nazi
robots that's freaky but I don't want
woke whiny baby robots either that are
they're scared of everything so how do
you how do you create Centrist AI you
know what I mean that's why I tweeted
enlightened Centrist AI it took me a
while to get it to say it the real
danger of the Nazis was the intolerance
and the violence so it doesn't matter
what you call yourself if you're
intolerant and violent that's the danger
that we're trying to avoid how would you
describe antifa today
uh violent intolerant yeah that's what
I'm talking about in 2020 when they're
burning down buildings and smashing up
those streets like that's what the Nazis
did it was for a different reason for
sure it was for a different reason so I
should point that out but Street
violence thuggery is what we're trying
to avoid intolerance hate just
irrational hatred of the other that's
what we're trying to avoid whatever it
doesn't matter what you call yourself
man it doesn't matter what you pin on
your shirt or what color you're wearing
or what color your skin is or what
accent you have it really doesn't matter
right
Behavior it's what you're actually doing
it is behavior well we also have to
understand too that violence and
thuggery and things like that these
things are not well they're bad but
they're the end result of a lot of
cultural indoctrination a lot of that is
actually the I'm talking I've said this
a thousand times you could give if if I
was offered the trade today where
Democrats could have every seat in the
house every seat in the Senate and the
United States presidency and I in return
would get every school board in the
United States of America I would take
that every single day of the week and
twice on Sunday we have lost our culture
from a very very early time in this
country and that eventually you have a
bunch of thugs as you pointed out
yelling at people sensors building AI
robots that are thugs that that's the
end result of an education system that
goes Way Beyond just school but we have
now a an education system in this
country from school to entertainment to
freaking sports to everything that tells
young people over and over and over
again America sucks America sucks
America sucks America sucks America
sucks and soon you go to communist
finishing school which we know as
universities in this country then you're
22 23 years old and can you have any job
yeah you've never had a job you've never
lived in the real world all the world
that's been beaming at you from your
phone or your TV has told you America is
a wretched place your social studies
teacher backed it up your history
teacher backed it up now you're 23 23
and you think you're fighting against
Nazis I've tried to explain this to
people that Democrats are not they're
not stupid when they do this Nazi white
supremacist stuff we like to roll our
eyes at it and make fun of them at it or
we'll do the lamest no I'm not a Nazi
that doesn't make sense they're doing it
for a purpose they're telling that
person who hated you anyway fine he's a
Nazi well if I was to give you a gun
right now Ian well maybe not you because
you're probably a lot nicer person Luke
if I was to give you a gun right now and
tell you there was no help against it
and I was to take Dr Mengele and sit him
in this chair right here what would you
do you'd fire a bullet in his head
without a moment of hesitation why
because you know that that's a truly
evil person they're calling you a Nazi
for a reason after turning you into a
hateful person and then they say hey
hateful person there's the problem but
but just to issue one minor caveat
there's a reason why we put the Nazis on
trial to make sure that everybody knew
exactly what they did right right so
when you catch these people I I do
believe that the the Civics the the
ideas of the founding fathers weren't
just about being fair it was about
proving you yourself right proving that
your leadership was correct the problem
is we don't put our evil people on trial
now we have oh seriously they get
promotions and Noble Peace prizes we had
a 51 increase in teenage girl suicides
during all the mask mandate code school
shutdowns that's now that that's just a
phone that's just a number right but
we're about to have Christmas in what 23
24 days how many parents in this country
are not going to have Christmas with
their baby girl because of something
that did no good whatsoever and the
person who put those policies in place
will never spend a day in jail we don't
put our criminals on trial now we
promote them like you mentioned they
want them to go to the media they stay
in the government our worst criminals
you brought up the mafia earlier let me
make a quick point on this you brought
up the mafia earlier because I I had
another Awakening moment in my life I
love mafia books and Mafia documentaries
and cartels and all the stuff guys geek
out on we all geek out on that stuff and
I used to roll my eyes every single time
I saw some wise guy murdered 10 people
and they're interviewing him in prison
and he'd say something to the effect of
uh government's the worst criminals out
there all the governments are worse and
I'd be oh wow what an idiot that guy was
100 right every single day the people in
our government should be in jail way
longer than that the government that is
the mafia let me let me just say
something that you guys know I love to
say
Barack Obama
murdered a 16 year old American who
committed no crime
abdulrahman who was eating at a civilian
Cafe in Yemen
Obama ordered a drone strike on civilian
infrastructure in a country we were not
at war with why well they say it was an
accident
I believe it's because his father Anwar
al-alaki was a Jihadi preaching against
the United States he was an American
citizen by the way and Obama killed him
too it's called an extrajudicial
assassination I think the reason the U.S
government killed Abdul Rahman was to
send a message if you screw with us the
United States will execute your children
yeah these are these are not good people
and it was crazy to me when uh like
hearing hearing prominent people say
that Obama was like one of the best
presidents and I'm like depends on what
your definition of best is if you're
talking about killing civilians overseas
with drone strikes in in countries and
at war with the if that's what you
consider the best people in this
government have killed for power and and
I gotta tell you man
that the story of abdulrahman al-alaki
is should shock the core of Americans he
was he was born in I think Boulder
Colorado was living in San Diego this is
an American kid and he went overseas to
visit extended family and they blew him
up and Barack Obama signed off on an
order assassinating a 16 year old
American citizen without a court without
a judge without a jury without nothing
and the only statement the whole Biden
administration of the whole Obama
administration gave regarding this whole
entire incident was to my news
organization and the only thing they had
to say is that he should have had a
better father that's absolutely insane
yeah that's the only thing they said
what was the question so Robert Gibbs
was Obama's right hand man he was
Obama's spokesperson we came to him and
we were like why did Obama personally
call off on the assassination of a 16
year old American citizen and he ignored
it he didn't answer it he didn't answer
we kept peppering we kept asking we kept
asking and then he said he just should
have had a better father that's
literally what he said and then was he
talking about Barack no abdura yeah
and then as soon as Trump came into
office the daughter uh gets taken out in
the raid 10 people that's questionable
as well seven of those people were
killed were children we just murdered in
Afghanistan ten of them and not only did
no one go to prison no one even got
fired in fact they said it was nobody's
fault John Kirby was asked about it and
they said is anyone at least going to
get fired or reprimanded I believe he
called it if memory serves well it was a
failure of process seven of those were
kids adorable kids go look up their
faces we murdered those kids no one went
to jail weddings uh hospitals all of
them were bombed by drones this is the
US government this is what propels in
many ways not the only way Maga because
for a lot of people I know they were
just like
Trump says he's gonna he's opposed to
war Hillary Clinton is a warmonger I
vote for Trump and then for me with I
didn't vote for him the first time the
second time he was he was actively
setting forth a plan to withdraw from
Afghanistan get get U.S out of here get
NATO debates fair share I'm like all of
these things are good we shouldn't be
doing these things we should be blowing
people up Trump did increase drone
strikes totally understand in the in and
and you deserve criticism for it I
suppose the argument is that in removing
Personnel from the Middle East he it
needed to be supplemented with something
less the Taliban actually come in and
take over like they did but at any rate
when Trump said he was getting our
troops out of Syria when he set a
deadline for Afghanistan I said if
that's the best I can get I'll take it
because Joe Biden is Democrat he's
clinton-esque it's going to be the same
warmongering garbage so
you know I I rant on that stuff but I
want to make sure people understand how
clear it is that when we talk about the
the worst people of History
there's there's little excuse for no
accountability with our current
politicians I can understand why you
might say like in World War II the US
did bad things with like internment
camps and stuff with the office of
censorship I'm like yeah those things
were bad I can understand why you might
say Abraham Lincoln creating a corridor
where he suspended habeas corpus really
really bad thing yeah the absolute
absolute power these are really really
bad things how about we have a modicum
of accountability if anyone just came
out when like introducing Obama and be
alike and we understand that times are
hard Obama did kill a 16 year old
American citizen without charge or trial
at the very least we can say it ladies
and gentlemen the president like we
could we can't even get that degree of
public accountability you know they get
a Nobel Peace Prize they get promoted
they get celebrated it's some kind of
great human beings as as really great
guys and essentially a lot of them are
just murderers I see like the liberal
economic order we we've basically since
World War II we're like no more world
wars like that no more dictators across
the sea to start spark up a war so we'll
put military bases everywhere air and by
thread of arms and murder will prevent
another dictator which essentially we
have there hasn't been a third world war
but the other option was we're going
full on isolationists we do not want to
military bases anywhere and then what
happened was Hitler appeared so like
I don't know do you see a third path
that's like not as aggro as military
bases all over Earth but not as hands
off as isolationism what's wrong with
isolationism that's what the country was
founded on George Washington's Farewell
Address his Farewell addressed people
could go read it to this day he is
explicit that we stay out of Europe's
Wars they basically said those freaking
people are always in a war we stay out
we trade with everybody we stand up
everyone's Wars no and that was the
foreign policy of the United States of
America up to World War one and it still
was and they still pulled some shady
crap to get us into World War one
because the public was so against
getting involved in that at all and then
fast forward to World War II Hitler's
invading Poland and all these things
there was still I think the numbers like
95 of Americans were all not my freaking
problem send them some armaments or
something like that that's not my
problem obviously Pearl Harbor brought
us in isolationism if that's what we
want to call it that is the foreign
policy this country was founded on and
we've gotten so far away from it now
that people think you actually have some
justification for some of the insane
crap we do out there it's nuts we're
gonna go to super chats if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this Channel right
now share the share with your friends
and become a member at timcast.com for
behind the scenes and uncensored shows
we have those up periodically Monday
through Thursday we have the uncensored
after show but Fridays we have the Green
Room although I think this week's Green
Room went up on Tuesday because it's yay
and we want to get it up quick but let's
read some super chats
Bobby Gibbons says used to work for vice
in the LA S2 office someone mentioned
your show to me I've been enjoying it
you guys need to get Adam Curry on keep
it up hey appreciate it I wonder when
you worked at the vice office in LA
because Vice you know started to change
a whole lot over the past 10 years I
worked there as like nine nine years ago
now but uh shout out to the people who
used to work for vice now don't and
enjoy the show we do stay true man I got
in touch with Adam Curry he was
definitely into coming on but we got to
get Tim to know who he is so that he's
cool
Adam Curry he's like they call him the
Pod father because they say he invented
the podcast he didn't actually invent it
but he had like one of the earlier
podcasts yeah Adam Curry I'm coming for
you and then you're coming here because
we're gonna talk Eric Knapp says Tim
your best chance of success with
freedomastan is to actually own your
property the best way is to own a
patented mining claim only five dollars
per year for taxes or for 20 acres one
in northern Idaho just sold for 270
acres for 600 000. yeah yeah Jay boring
says my name is Jeremy boring please
help me get connect acted with the CEO
of the daily wire the two Jeremy borings
need to unite that's very interesting
Jeremy boring
okay let's grab some rye Lyon says my
favorite anti-comi please ask him to
find my email to him about ESG and
pensions 401ks which Carol Roth told him
about everyone needs to be absolutely
angry about it what is what is that
about you know
well uh
excuse me oh did you inhale the whiskey
I did it went down the wrong place
all right ESG people already know about
ESG on your show the same when I was on
Rogan I sipped water and held it and
then for like five minutes I'm like yeah
that was whiskey anyway
so ESG everyone knows what a yes she is
what's happening is they're moving
Pension funds listen to my voice
and give yourself a good hard coffee so
they're moving Pension funds now into
ESG so if you have a pension fund you
expect that pension fund to
automatically make money that's what
Pension funds do they're not doing that
anymore now now they're allowing them
because of a department of uh SEC rule
they're allowing them to take your
pension fund it invested in all this
Enviro crap which is not paying off
blackrock's even moving away from it
doesn't pay so they're they're blowing
your pension in the name of climate
change man that's what FTX did they
basically in the name of righteousness
they started investing their own
people's money in like
impact investment stuff like that it was
it's such good whiskey that you just
inhaled it people are gonna clip that be
like why is he so sad about pensions
we had uh Lauren Southern who was
drinking out of a paper cup and this is
the Papi uh Kentucky bourbon and then
Jesse who inhaled it it was so good I
want to get this straight so this is
blackrock's taking people's money into
impact investing it what's happening is
like you know what ESG is obviously so
it's really bad it's really stupid it's
it's governments and corporations
merging together for all this climate
change NDC it doesn't matter but it's
bad it doesn't make money there's no
money in it all right so what they're
doing is they're passing rules There are
rules that say you can't you have to try
to do what's best for somebody with
their pension fund you have an
obligation to that person because
they're giving money to their pension
fund you have an obligation to try to
make them money they're essentially
giving them an out now and saying well
not really I mean you should but if you
also want to do ESG that's fine too so
they're taking and people won't know I
was uh it was a little while ago two
three months ago I was sitting out back
uh at my neighbor's house in my
neighborhood all these couples are out
there and they're all people who almost
all of them vote Republican they're
they're you know restaurant managers guy
owns a small construction business just
normal people but they they're
relatively interested in politics not
one of them even knew what ESG was when
I brought it up to them they thought I
was lying and I told them I said pick up
your phone right now and look up your
bank and ESG I guarantee your bank has
its own ESG page they had no idea what
it was nobody knows what it is no I
should say normal people don't know what
it is and now they darn sure don't know
that their pension that they're working
hard for is going to be moved into it so
your pension that you think you're gonna
get at the end you ain't but hey at
least you saved Mother Earth all right
let's read this for Mr Obvious says this
is concrete proof that Twitter colluded
with Democrats to rig elections we must
investigate YouTube and Facebook as well
this is nuclear
this is so let's let's break it down
they met IB mentions that the Trump
campaign did have removals that were
honored but this is this is exactly the
point Twitter's staff is mostly Democrat
so most of the rules benefit them they
have the misgendering policy it clearly
benefits their perspective in world view
Democrats with their connections were
able to get Twitter to take down
unflattering and damaging information
that ultimately benefited them within a
couple weeks of an election
this is public manipulation and election
interference now I suppose we need to
have I guess adjudication this how do we
solve that if Republicans aren't going
to do anything about it I don't know can
they do anything about it do they have
any institutions that they could
actually get some kind of Justice here
I mean is there anything to make a do
technically uh Congress can can and they
can make criminal referrals and do all
those things but I think the issue is
was it really illegal is it illegal for
a private Corporation to take down posts
at the behest of a political campaign I
don't think it's criminal I don't think
it's criminal either the only thing the
only way we're going to be able to do
anything about any of this stuff if you
really want something done it's going to
have to come at the state level like
like fauci was just deposed recently it
wasn't Congress it did it wasn't the doj
it wasn't anybody it was Eric Schmidt
God bless his soul uh AG current AG is
about to be a senator from the state of
Missouri he's the one who locked it down
and got fauci to come down and depose
fouching things like that the state AGS
the state AGS are really really a huge
key you need aggressive State Governors
and state AGS because again like I
talked about earlier in the show they
have huge Power Man fauci's up there
he's king of this and king of that Eric
Schmidt said no come on down to Missouri
we're going to have a little chat on
camera and that's what it is you know
about the lawsuit coming out of Missouri
with uh against uh what is it Which
social platform is it Facebook or is it
YouTube that's the same Twitter same
basic thing Twitter
and those guys that's exactly what it is
that's why George Soros spent so much
money on the AG race but uh what about a
conspiracy charger election interference
charge I don't think I don't I don't
think it's illegal for a political
campaign to say hey can you take take
down a post I don't think it is either
but what if it's an act in government in
power they weren't went afterwards yeah
right so they did and they they still do
it right right that's that's the stuff
from the lawsuit we've discovered so
yeah we'll need hearings let me let me
read this from frumps he says Jeremy at
the quartering had his biggest night
ever and probably sold a lot of coffee
regardless this has been a really wacky
week Ian is still Zen somehow speed the
Collapse by Metric uh I'm gonna be
honest with you frumps the only reason I
read that is because you mentioned speed
the Collapse by Metric and they're like
the best band ever so let's speed the
collapse is one of my favorite songs but
no yeah shout out Jeremy uh I guess he
he had a big night congratulations on
some coffee uh it right on man let's
grab some more Super chats
Garrett targeting says shouted your pod
out on the taibi thread as a hopefully
helpful redirect keep it keep rocking
man shout out to Matt tahibi he gained
like 300K followers gonna crack a
million taibi's fantastic he he was like
a rolling stone journalist he was kind
of a liberal guy but he was like a
freedom guy he was an honest guy and
then when things started to shift and
get weird he's like I'm out I'm not
going to keep doing this I'm doing my
own thing launches his own sub stack and
and is stuck to it doing legitimate
reporting he was I think he's the
reporter who basically confirmed that
Victor shoken in Ukraine had active
investigations into barisma where Hunter
Biden was working because before this
the media kept claiming the Ukrainian
prosecutor wasn't even investigating
Biden or brisma or anything like that
then taibi did the actual journalism
came out and said here's a dozen
investigations that were opened by this
prosecutor into barisma and they fired
him and it's like there it is and Joe
Biden by the way is on camera bragging
that he got that Prosecuting fired
that's right there's also news on
Twitter right now that James Woods is
going to be suing the D and see for
damage is done to his career whoa that's
legitimate yeah this is uh Kyle Morris
reporting on this right now and he's a
reporter for Fox News and that's what
he's coming out and saying yeah I'll
retweet it right now I just retweeted it
good he's I'm glad he's moving on that
that's political Luke we are change
James Woods did he announce on Twitter
that he's doing it because he's on
Twitter this is according to the uh yeah
James Wood would be awesome I love James
he's great people yeah and not to
mention he's a great actor yeah he's the
best one of the best Family Guy
characters himself yeah it was insane
and stalking Peter he's great he's great
plus uh wasn't he in Hercules he was
Hades I think he was in a movie I think
it was within Michael J fox I almost
believe a long long time ago I think it
was called the hard way and that is an
underrated movie nobody's seen I love me
some James Woods yep 1991.
it's a John batam movie and there's also
going to be a another Twitter reveal
tomorrow uh Elon Musk is promising on
Saturday yep you know Ryan savedra made
a great point he's like why are you
doing this on Friday night where news
goes today you're on seven 24 7 baby
elon's all day every day oh yes we could
have used this news earlier in the week
to be completely honest that's true yeah
that was a good tweet you had earlier by
the way oh about Hunter no no about
coming on this show oh [ __ ] what did you
say I said hey look the good news is no
matter what happens I won't be the worst
guest they've had this week
all right let's see James Grayson says
shout out to Serge he's doing an amazing
he's he's doing amazing producing IRL
surgery yeah level man trying to do
better every time cameras audio all that
you said you got synesthesia is that
accurate yes that's accurate so you you
see color or you see uh you see color
you see words you see noise like what
how is it when you speak the word text
floats out of your mouth and then flies
away
what's a brief like example we know we
know weiner wiener uh it's a basically
like it depends which means blending of
the senses and I'm sure you know that as
well uh so it depends on which kind of
Senses you have Blended for me it's like
my vision and it's like my textural
touch there's a couple different this
pressure touch and then there's textural
touch and then there's also my auditory
as well so but it's not like it's not
like an acid trip I think like Facebook
gets it all wrong it gave it like they
show oh as soon as he's just like an
adjective it's not like that guys come
on you got Ian interested I'm on board
yeah he's like how do I get this suffer
from that is that the way to put I
experience that sometimes too but it's
definitely if weed's involved then I'll
be like whoa now I'm really hearing the
shapes interesting actually they say LSD
opens parts of the brain that activate
them at the same time where you perceive
shape and sound so that you start to
like hear shapes and stuff like that
it's similar it makes your those neurons
connect in a way they hadn't connected
on previously which is similar to what
you experience when you have censorship
but essentially just all the time
basically all right Raymond g Stanley Jr
says Tim after tonight I'm feeling good
this is Tiger Blood style we will win I
hope I'm not the only one this
optimistic and so we forward the line
yeah I'm saying like this this past the
past week or so it's been absolutely
fantastic the week before this Elon Musk
is tremendous victories putting out more
information is just victory victory
victory the after the midterms you know
it was weird to see everybody down like
why did we do so bad and I'm like the
Republicans won the house like that's
all they could have gotten winning the
Senate would have been good I get it but
it's not has any laws they're going to
get subpoena power they're going to get
committee power in the house they're
going to get rid of Nancy Pelosi it's
like take the win then realize ballot
harvesting is a huge problem and then
after you do ballot Harvest for 2024
wherever it's legal right yeah and then
once you win you can fix it
all right
Chris Lee bear says Jesse Kelly looks
like Ultra based Russell Brand Ian
you're the best
thanks
you think that was a you think it's
worth using the enemy's tactics against
them to win I think you're right that I
said there's no we're not at a war in
the United States but the whole like
Opium Wars it never really ended for the
the Communist Chinese party this year so
maybe we are is it is it worth using
like like I think was it Raymond g
Stanley was saying
uh how did he phrase it that he would
use that it's like of course of course
we use their tactics against them we
should not adopt everything they're
doing and do it right back you're saying
ballot Harvest and then when you get in
fix it absolutely do every we should do
everything they're doing and do it
better than they do of course we should
I I agree and I would probably just
phrase it as like be the 2.0 you know so
do we want to use their technique
against them we want to use better
versions of their tactics of course we
need to be as mean and vicious as they
are I mean people like like people think
uh people think we won World War II in
the Pacific you know and that what did
they picture when they picture that they
picture you know the flag going up on
Mount sarabachi and some some handsome
Marine with a rifle in his hands we won
the World War II in the Pacific by
taking uh satchel charges and chucking
them and chucking them into caves where
we knew women and children were with the
Japanese and blowing them up but we had
to adopt horrible tactics to beat
horrible people that's how you do it so
if if it's legal in this country and we
can do it to hurt the Communists let's
do it Hayden says what are everyone's
opinions on Balkans where would each of
you draw the lines single state is a
cop-out and bro code violation okay what
do you think about balkanization it's a
national divorce what it is right now is
it's inevitable that you already saw
what happened people talk a lot about
Florida and what a great uh what a great
midterm they had and Florida's all red
now and and and they they did but people
miss an important part of that Rhonda
santis won by 20 30 000 votes I think it
was the first time and then won by over
a million last time now yes he's been a
very good Governor that's part of it but
another part of it is people have moved
to the state and voted that way you
should move you should leave your crappy
blue hell hole and go live around people
who share your values I've lived all
over the country blue red and I'm
telling you it's a better life I I did
think that
but now I think something else
you know we moved out here because I was
I was I was of that mentality and then I
started thinking one of the reasons like
you mentioned that DeSantis does so well
is because a lot of people moved to
Florida but then we also see Democrats
do really really well in places that are
surprising even in New York where it
shifted right in a lot of ways Democrats
still end up winning and it's probably
because half a million more
right-leaning people more moderate
people fled the state so now I'm
thinking I don't know maybe people who
live in red areas should start moving
and mass as sort of like a colonization
of urban areas and then colonizing their
hyper partisan political views in these
spaces if you could organize that in any
way I would agree with you the problem
is like Miami people have people have
their priorities in an order right all
priorities are not the same mine are
ordered well I have I have two sons to
raise am I going to pack up my sons and
go uh have them go step over poop in San
Francisco so San Francisco can go red
nope I don't think so I'll be right here
screw San Francisco all right Matthew
Winfield this was the Super Chat I was
looking for because I saw it before and
it's very good he says Tim Vijay
explained how to correct pronounce her
name in the first 30 seconds of The Joe
Rogan podcast with you and Jack saying
it right is the least we can do since
she might be going to jail soon
well that's what everyone said it's been
years since I was there
I just know I'm not trying it that's all
good job
yeah Gotti
okay let's grab some more Super chats I
feel like in the vein of balkanization
really quick that the United States is
wonderful and that it was already set up
to be sort of balkanized already so that
we don't have to split apart in order to
have different areas that are different
which is one of the great Natures of
State unification all right Nicholas uh
did jarnat says with Jesse's smarter but
meaner claim is DeSantis next in line
I thought remaining to be seen he's got
to go beat Donald Trump first I'm not on
team Trump or I'm not on team DeSantis
I'm on team I don't trust any of you and
every single one of you has to go earn
my vote yeah maybe look this Santos has
been a great Governor there's no
question about that go beat Donald Trump
show me you can win true that I agree
and I think that a primary between the
two of them would make both of them
better candidates Donald Trump needs
that primary too Donald Trump's still
out there pushing vaccines and insane
he's still he's still out there being
president Pfizer he's still sitting down
with New York Times reporters for three
days who hate his freaking guts and then
complaining when they when Donald Trump
needs to be better so if we need a
better Trump let's go get a better Trump
he still talks about 2020 over and over
Rhonda Santos is going to be like here's
my plan for America he puts he's putting
that book out he's going to talk about
China and then Trump's going to have to
be like I've got to address these issues
too if Trump keeps talking about 2020
Donald Trump's going to lose the 20 the
2024 primary here he is well Donald
Trump has no incentive to stop talking
about the 2020 re-election unless Ron
DeSantis gets in and forces him to
change if you are a trump fan a hardcore
Trump fan good for you fly that flag you
should want Ron DeSantis in the race and
if you're Ron DeSantis fan maybe you're
flying that flag you should want him to
have to face against Donald Trump iron
sharpens iron go fight go run my vote
politicians should all be treated like
rental cars anyway all of them all right
Frump says Jesse Rollins straight 20s
sounds like you have TDS how dare you
not love and adore our president Trump
oh okay I dare you not worship at the
altar and approve every one of these
moves no matter what I like Donald Trump
I like Donald Trump just fine but I'm
not loyal to any po I'm as loyal to
politicians as they are to me which is
not at all exactly all right free men
Die free says the only way to help the
Chinese people liberate themselves to
overthrow the tyrants in our own
government
yeah and prayer not out of the question
also good music culture you just got to
give them give them the inside I mean
you got to get you got to get in the
minds of the people in the Chinese
government and get them to question
their own behavior
uh media social media Dr Ransom says Ian
is the chosen one I love your passion
brother keep the faith
oh well thanks I don't know we're all
pretty awesome Delta Tango says best
guest ever period
yeah a lot of people people kept saying
you were rolling 20s whenever you were
saying stuff it means that like in
Dungeon to dragons if you roll the die
to see if you're succeeding you're like
my character is going to steal this loaf
of bread you roll the die if you hit a
20. it's called critical success so it's
like the best ever it's perfect it's oh
nice yes they're praising you happy I'm
rolling 20s for y'all
rolling 20s okay what language is this
one I can't read it oh that's Greek
Greek huh Psalms 37 13 but the Lord
laughs at the wicked for he sees that
his day is coming interesting
what do we have off-road addicts as
strong men make good times good times
make weak men weak men make bad times
bad times make strong men
and that's basically like the fourth
turning you know we go through these
seasons of generations
you get a generation of people who have
to struggle and fight as hard as
possible and then they become gritty and
tough and they have kids who bask in the
wealth of that hard-earned success who
then have kids who have no idea where
any of that came from and don't learn
the lessons from their from their
ancestors or fathers who have kids who
are whiny soft lazy while it's a cookie
dough you said you were in the Marines
Jesse was that just like chaos were you
in combat I was I I was uh in the
initial Iraq invasion from the beginning
wow the 2000 or two yeah do you feel
like it made you a better person
probably not well no it no that's that's
that's not fair it grew me up it grew me
up it was 2003 by the way 2003 was the
initial Invasion the Fallujah
I'm sorry how old were you when you went
23 I think no no I think I was 22 and I
think I turned 23 there I forget but I
think that yep no I was I was 22 and I
turned 23 there was revealing straight
shooter says would I be able to unlock
Jesse's phone with two mirrors
[Laughter]
I don't you know what we're trying it
right now I wonder if I can take this
off oh and hold your case up to your
phone and see if it I'm too paranoid to
set that up but for me it's just a
passcode I was like no fingerprints no
face code I don't trust it no it's not
working dang it doesn't work
good effort I think he could buy a mask
that does allow you to open up
um and have facial recognition recognize
you officially but it needs to be like
3D like I could have a mask of you and
open up your phone yes I'd love to have
a mask of me
do it there's a there's this image
that's been going around for like a
decade of a mask to avoid facial
recognition and everyone everyone will
like periodically grab it and be like it
looks like Temple because you know for
whatever reason it does look like yeah
it looks exactly like yeah I think it
also has a beanie too somebody uh
where's that where's that chat that I
thought was kind of funny where where'd
it go front says pool stash is starting
to look genghis-ish looks good though
you have a little Genghis it's a it's
the Korean Japanese you know oh yeah it
works the Genghis in there it's that
what is it called the Fu Manchu or
something when the hair comes that's
what it's called I should just let it
keep going I just had to shave in a
mustache because I lost a bit about the
election that the wife hated it hated it
oh there you go man you had to shave in
the mustache oh you brought it in it was
out no I had to shave off the beard and
just leave the mustache in there I think
it was fantastic she didn't agree this
is an interesting Luke may have to
verify Billy says not sure if it's been
talked about but apparently Schwab uh
was confirmed to have had a heart attack
and Google is suppressing it in search
with the results are changing quickly I
heard about the rumors uh last night and
there's a lot of different people saying
that he did have a heart attack I
haven't been able to officially confirm
it but that's the rumors that are going
out there now I heard that he got a
second had a second heart attack
probably total lie I don't know but it
would be his second if that was healing
it was his third heart that had a heart
attack but his other two kept going so
he was totally fine it's the great
moment
um when when God will look back at What
You Did In This Moment you want to pray
for your enemies good luck you know good
health yeah we should never celebrate
death or someone getting hurt yeah I
think and and uh that's ridiculous yeah
but I think the system will continue to
celebrate death well it depends on who's
dead
totally depends on who's dead I'd
celebrate death all the time if it was
some evil piece of trash I I wouldn't I
wouldn't I would disagree
um I I would uh but not completely I'm
not saying it's it's absolute I'm saying
like there are circumstances where where
you're in a war and there's someone
who's like mercilessly killing and
beating people and you have no choice
but to stop them I understand that's a
circumstance well if you have some guy
out there who's been abusing children
horribly for years and he gets
splattered across on the highway I'm
gonna pop a bottle of champagne I don't
have any I'm not I'm not sad even the
least yeah yeah I I couldn't do it I
couldn't do it like like a like a Hitler
kind of thing where you've got a brutal
merciless dictator it's just a matter of
what you think is horrible I mean it's
read some story the other day I hate
these freaking stories now that I'm a
parent it's a parents tortured their
three or four-year-old child to death
those people died tomorrow I think I was
fantastic but I I my view is more so to
stop an active threat
you know that's that and look that's
look it's different than someone who has
better people than me I'm not justifying
my point of view I'm just saying that
that's how I feel and I'm just I'm not
saying I'm right but that's how yeah we
can agree to disagree I'm still sticking
by my mind I think we're both right
which is the crazy thing about being
human is this weird contradiction of
like War and Peace that's that's the
thing like I'm not I'm not trying to say
I'm just trying to explain myself
because you explain yourself you know my
my view is such that um I think we're
better people when we can show people
how we've subdued an evil person and
then explain to everybody what they did
why it was wrong and put and show them
to the world like like I was mentioned
with the Nuremberg trials yeah but uh
but yeah you know I oppose a death
penalty but a lot of people point out
their circumstances where unfortunately
you know War being one of them evil
people doing evil Things Push us into a
vision where we we have to stop them
from doing these evil things like if if
you saw somebody trying to kidnap a
child you have to stop that person you
have to you know what I mean well let's
grab we'll grab some more Super chats
Brandon says this was better than Milo's
episode sorry Milo oh heavens it just
keeps getting better all right well uh
we'll wrap up there I suppose if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to the
channel share the show with your friends
become a member at timcast.com click
that join us button we have members only
shows all week Monday through Thursday
uncensored members only and then Friday
is the Green Room show but earlier today
earlier this week we had yay and then we
also had the cast Castle Vlog which um I
think we have a new episode coming up
soon we're just producing them as we can
and trying to make the best that we can
so I really do appreciate all of your
support over at timcast.com you can
follow me at timcast you can follow the
show at timcast IRL Jesse do you want to
shout anything out uh Jesse Kelly show
every every weeknight they podcast the
show when you're done watching or done
watching Tim cast Go download the
podcast enjoy it where where can they
find it and what's your social media
it's on iHeart Google Spotify iTunes
just look up Jesse Kelly show and my
social media if you're interested in
that I'm really fantastic on there at
Jessie Kelly DC on Twitter and Instagram
Jesse that was great thank you so much
for coming on earlier in the show I said
if you're at the parks department you're
you're a communist or if you believe in
the parks department you're a communist
someone in the chat room was like hey
but I work in the parks department I
literally I went in the chat room and I
was like you're communist and so I'm
engaging with you guys in the chat room
the chat room is awesome I appreciate
you guys very much but it's not as
awesome as the chat room on Luke
uncensored.com my website where of
course I have a forum I've been doing a
lot of videos there the latest one is
about Balenciaga lots of crazy stuff
happening there including full-on
conversations The Forum is amazing all
on Luke uncensored.com by signing up you
guys support me hope to see you guys
there after this show thanks for having
me wild week but man communication uh
friendship I think these are the some of
the tenets of getting through these
crazy you know metamorphosi that we're
experiencing as a human species right
now Jesse hell yeah dude good to see you
appreciate you my brother appreciate you
boys having me it was awesome oh yeah
absolutely dude this is great tens good
job catch you later Serge yo a lot of
20s for me Ian's today it was good a lot
of 20s from you as well great stuff uh
this is a great show I really appreciate
everyone watching this has been fun and
this is probably one of the better ones
I enjoy I watch these conversations all
the time you know and I think this is
probably up there with Milos maybe
better I don't know good conversation
you know it's always good to have a
conversation and um yeah I'm at
surge.com everywhere try and get to me
on Instagram so I can get over 2 000
followers guys what a crazy week to say
the least so thanks for hanging out
we'll have Clips up throughout the
weekend we got the big library of
uncensored stuff over at timcast.com
other than that thanks for hanging out
we'll see you all next week cheers